all right hey what's going on everybody
it's Bill Byrne it's time for the
Thursday afternoon just before Friday
Monday Morning podcast just checking in
on you seeing how your week's going and
once again once again I have an amazing
guest this is what Thursdays are
becoming amazing guests with Mr Bill
Burr we have the one and only from uh
real-time uh Bill Maher is with us here
who is uh he's plugging he's got a date
uh the Hulu theater in Madison Square
Garden yes on the 12th of this month
November that's amazing is that where
Eddie did uh raw I don't know I think he
did really yeah I don't think that's
also I don't think the Hulu theater well
they renamed it they renamed okay well
it's Madison Square Garden if you can't
find that you're not enough uh right you
know what else happened there that was
where that whole East Coast West Coast
rap thing started is that right that's
what uh Snoop was going you guys don't
have any love for the west coast and and
and shook was saying you know all up in
the videos come on you know this stuff I
love the energy that you start this show
with I mean like he'll bring me down
what I do I stay at this level of energy
to stay ahead of the fog of my
depression what are you depressed about
your career is going fantastic what am I
that's that's what fills you up that's
that's the BS that's like and then I do
this and then then I I do uh two
episodes of ER and then I'll love myself
where seriously you're not happy
um no I am happy okay I am happy before
you touch me but I do know I do know
that like if if uh if I slow down too
much and I really take it all in yeah I
don't like the movie well I I do I do
understand that okay I mean I only live
for the future also like like the past
offer some people are like they really
get a lot of joy out of memories it's
like I nothing I mean because it's gone
it's only about tomorrow do you throw
stuff out do you hold on to things
I am very selective I'm I'm very neat so
I do hold on to things but it fits into
like I'm very big on files I have many
files like I'm not a car guy but I have
files up the ass I have them in the
garage I have in my office
like a very very good files like Fire
King files they are fireproof and they
are strong some of them have had for 30
years they've lasted what's in there
everything like like every year I keep a
file of just like stuff from that year
that just reminds me of what happened in
the year notes and things that happened
like you know so you are a little
sentimental well I live in a very office
type of way it's not really for
sentimentalities I call it being a good
caveman because when I want to look back
and know what happened in 1991 or
something I can look at that file and
know who I was I want to be a Good
anthropologist for my own life oh all
right
now when you go back have you ever how
well how often do you go into those file
cabinets that's what I want to know like
is this something like every Friday
night it's not let's see Bill Maher in
1988. it's not often but I did have the
occasion I won't even tell you why to
look back at like the beginnings like
stuff that uh from like age 12 to 14. I
was looking at with with someone we were
laughing our asses off oh all right uh
about it because you know I kept a
little Journal I started when I was like
14 or something and it's just of course
hysterical I mean what goes through your
mind and what you're thinking and
um I mean like in that file there were
things like I had sent away to WABC
radio in New York for the Hot 100 Songs
of the year three years in a row and
they you know if you sent away with the
self-addressed stamped envelope they
would send you the list of them yes what
were the top 100 songs I guess that this
was by sales back then now it's
streaming and who knows right I mean
it's made up Taylor Swift has the top 10
songs now on the charts well that could
never happen back when they actually
tabulated who did the best by who went
to a record store and bought it the
Beatles once had the top I think four or
five but that's only because they had
the whole backlog from 63 before they
had broken here in America so like when
they had I want to hold your hand was
their first hit in America but they had
a she loves you had been a hit in
England the year before and a couple of
their other singles so they had like
five songs in the top ten that will
never happen again for real right but
she is a really good uh I I respect how
oh sure a good business person she is
that she realized that she was getting
screwed over by her label and then tried
to create something else I forget if
that worked yeah what they give you like
for every 90 million views like she gets
she gets like half a cent I mean I love
how like like the internet set us
artists free for like half a second
before the business people came doing
like the end around like right now
they're signing new comics and they're
and they're like owning their podcasts
and getting it and I'm trying to tell
every young comic I need like you don't
[ __ ] need these guys they can't get
you advertising if you don't have
listeners you're gonna get all of this
stuff and then what's going to happen is
is if you leave that agency it's it's
like they're gonna get your money for
the rest of time it was like back in the
day if you booked a sitcom with one in
in your agent was at whatever uh William
Morris and then you left to for Gersh
the whole time you did that sitcom you
owed William Morris the money they're
going to do that with like podcasts
where the [ __ ] do you see young Comics
what do you mean I go out to the clubs
bill you do yeah you have to it keeps
you young as far as like you're still
like I'm still 54 but like you can't go
out don't I used to watch a lot of guys
from your generation who were my
generation 12 years older you're a
boomer man you're [ __ ] talking about
the Beatles
okay so you're 12 years what's her face
okay by the way it's so much better than
by the way by the way to anyone under 30
we're the same
okay so tell me like your generation to
you no no but I'm saying as a I was
coming up your stand-up generation right
okay during the Heyday of the sitcom
yeah can we can we meet on that ground
I saw a number of people who were like
series regulars or had their own sitcom
right and you know the whole thing was
once you got like into that third season
and I got rolling and you were working
towards syndication back when that was a
thing and you'd have this Avalanche of
money I saw a handful of those guys just
stopped doing stand-up and then come
back oh after like six seven years
that's like leaving music for six seven
years how much it changes and I watched
them like really struggle I mean they
eventually figured it out but that's why
I kind of learned that lesson it's just
like I need to this is like going to the
gym I have to do that I mean but I go to
the gym but I just don't do it in the
clubs I mean I'm I'm always on the road
almost every not every weekend but like
every other weekend I mean yeah but I'm
not in front of your fans though right
that's different it's a layup they're
there to see you exactly why would I
torture myself and go in front of people
who don't understand she's gonna lose
your Edge man I do not lose my Edge
trust me my Edge I just did a special it
was on earlier this year called adulting
it's very I mean trust me I'm surprised
I wasn't canceled from it yeah but who's
going to cancel you obviously young
people do as you say you are by the way
you and I anybody could get canceled in
the next 30 Years wait you're one of the
first guys when you had a political
incorrect yes that's right I forgot
about that excuse me I I was literally
canceled okay they literally took your
show away yes when canceling meant
actually being yes but our younger view
was he had a show called Politically
Incorrect which was fantastic the the it
was just you hosted and then you had
just four completely different people
right you he would have like you know
onward on with like slash and then they
would just start talking I love the
choice of onwards I was trying to think
of something perfect I was trying to
think of so many political I actually
saw him I saw him do a gig out in front
of the White House
we went to we went to Washington DC in
the early 80s and onward Sadat was there
no yeah and he gave a speech I saw him
live man that's like seeing the stones
right no no it's like seeing Jim
Morrison because he's not here anymore
boy how about the way he bought the farm
huh
I mean that was bizarre for you guys who
don't know he was watching a military
parade of his own country and as he's
watching one of the trucks pull off
everybody jumped off and just started
shooting at him with machine guns right
and his security trying to bury him in
chairs well it was his own security
people who were killing him yeah same
same way that world leader thing is
that's a tough gig a tough gig same way
and Dara Gandhi got it you know
sometimes the people around you who you
was that Mahatma Gandhi's brother no no
no
Gandhi is a man that was a deep cut no a
deep cut uh no Adara Gandhi was the
leader of India not related to the other
Gandhi so that name's like Sullivan over
there it's very common actually the name
Patel is even more common I think like
the number of people in India named
Patel there's some stat I read like if
it was a country it would be like you
know the number one 18th largest country
ever been over there India yeah no no no
I did a gig over there man it was
amazing come on a gig yeah you did a gig
in India yeah it was amazing what and
I'll tell you the people they're [ __ ]
hilarious they're ball Breakers when I I
called up this podcast and they were
just talking to me going like hey you
gonna talk about this and I was like ah
you know I don't know they're going to
talk about that they just kept leading
me on these so you can talk about
religion or something and I was like you
know I don't I go wait are you guys
talking about this stuff and then they
started laughing they were trying to get
me in trouble what city was this uh
Mumbai which used to be Bombay of course
no kidding all right I'm not trying to
get off okay I get it you have a globe
no no no
Mumbai Mumbai yes it's the city that was
attacked so viciously in 2008. you
remember the attack Protestants
the Amish I believe was yeah I love a
water no no who was it was uh it was
Pakistan is it Pakistan it was a Muslim
attack on Hindu India I mean and boy did
they I mean they went through that City
that that hotel that they attacked I
think they made a movie about it the
hotel Mumbai or something yeah well when
I was there that yeah they had like
people with like machine guns oh and
stuff out front but it was like uh
they were uh they're beautiful people
man they were all jammed in together and
you think that they'd be like New York
right but they weren't they you know I'm
not gonna lie to you there was people
walking around with t-shirts that said
real men don't rape and I was like uh
what's what's up with that you're like
that's really not here that's a little
bit yeah it's like all right every
country's got you know their old school
Times Square you know that's who that
city is one of the
the greatest income inequality examples
in the world because there's
billionaires there's a house there that
is like I don't know something like I
don't know 50 stories high or something
and the guy owns the whole thing right
and then there are the slum dogs I mean
there are people who literally live in
that sewage I mean what their immune
systems must be like over there just
incredible yeah no it was it was a uh I
don't think they need the vaccine no I
Really they are the vaccines I think
they they're good yeah no but it was uh
it was quite a
I would go back in a second that's how
much I enjoyed it I would go back in a
second it's just I got two kids now and
I I it's just such a long flight to try
to get back there but I would go back
there
in a second and the perspective it gives
you you know how cool they are how funny
they are and then all the stuff that
they're dealing with and like just all
just going over to Asia was amazing to
travel over there because they literally
have everything that we have but just
different people doing it right down
they have their own rock stars their own
airplanes and stuff and you stay here
and you think oh everybody is into what
we're doing and they're over there and
they don't give a [ __ ] and their own
movie yeah it's amazing Bollywood I mean
it's a whole entire movie industry up
there that is different than ours
elves but you like watch it and you're
kind of like oh this is their Bruce
Willis I get this guy right no it's it's
because there are just so many stories
to tell uh but how did they know you
over there from podcast podcast really
from podcast yeah podcast people like uh
uh they they I guess I have people
Netflix I have people Netflix your
special is huge on Netflix yeah that's
fantastic by the way um oh thank you and
then there's uh other there's people in
countries they're not supposed to be
listened to it will reach out and tell
me that they listen I never say what
countries because I don't know what goes
on the black van pulls up I don't want
to be a part of it right but like it's
it's a really like uh
yeah no it's great like um I was in
Italy one time and some kid from like
Serbia or something came up to me
because you built bar and he said it
with the accent I said yeah he goes he
goes hey Monday Morning podcast go [ __ ]
yourself
like you got to be kidding me I go you
listen to that [ __ ] yeah I got a picture
with them and everything was awesome I
played Europe in 2015. I I did the
English-speaking places you can play uh
Oslo Stockholm did you do obviously
London you got to do them Amsterdam
I did that one was amazing the Midwest
the Midwest of Europe is what I call
like we did uh uh what the hell were we
uh
so no we did last week no but we did we
when Warsaw we did like four cities in
Germany
uh uh uh Budapest
uh Prague Vienna and dude you can just
go over there the English is so good
right you can just do your act just do
it yeah when I was in Budapest I was
like in the middle of my second one I
should have taped this this is like a
special right they were that great and
they loved uh anything you did if you
made fun of that country or you made fun
of your country right gold yeah gold and
I always feel it's kind of good to do
that if you make fun of yourself they
realize you're not coming Like A pompous
ass but you also make fun of them you're
not going there to like kiss their ass
or whatever but uh like I have fun in
Germany talking to them
saying like you know all the amazing
stuff you guys did with like you know
audio tape and space you know you pick
one you pick one wrong guy yeah one
monkey you just can't and they were just
sitting there like they was like
well they must get it all the time and
and the truth well yeah I mean but
there's also other [ __ ] going on there I
mean yes and it's unfair but you know to
people who are Germans today because it
was a long time ago they had nothing to
do with it yeah and I always think about
the Nazis like every group of people at
some point has tried to take over the
world I mean yeah everybody gets their
turn in the barrel like doing that those
are my favorite nor McDonald's jokes was
saying how Germany was the size of Maine
and they tried to take over the world
and they almost did it uh Germany was
never the size of Maine Germany is a
large country it isn't it is not
compared to us it isn't not quite
compared to us but in Europe it is I
found your your button your button is uh
geography
you get all prickly no I'm just I'm just
Mumbai Mumbai sorry and also Germany is
a large country and and German peoples
live outside of Germany that's one
reason why Hitler was it was taking over
little parts of Europe on the expats I'm
saying what it says they're not expats
they're just pockets of German people
Czechoslovakia has German people that's
right he went in not refugees he went
into this who didn't land because he was
quote on quote protecting ethnic Germans
there he went into alsus Lorraine on the
other side of Germany Germany is a
fairly big country and you just
downsized that you said Jeremy's a big
country now he's saying fairly big just
saying why do we have to have this
adversarial relationship because it's
fun okay all right but uh you know I
read your book a long time ago which one
the the stand true story oh goodwick and
all of that I love that book oh thank
you yeah now when you I mean when you
started stand up you literally like
there was so few rooms right before the
whole did you start before that or was
that just in the book that you were
talking about that again we're 12 years
difference in Edge I mean you make it
sound like a difference
I don't think it's as big a difference
it was the compact disc you were like
[ __ ] LPS
okay buy a bag of grass
this is what you need this is what you
need to make yourself feel young you do
no no no well I know now it's not big
deal but like when I live you were 24.
you're like a mustache and [ __ ] okay but
when I was 20. when I was 36 you were
24. the older you get the more alive
like you become now that you're no but
I'm talking about back then I started in
1992 rather than 1980 that's a big
[ __ ] difference as far as where stand
up is okay great do you have that if
that makes you feel good then you do I
was trying to find out about stand-up
yes well we we had we had crude tools uh
back then uh and there was no
electricity so we had to like shout the
jokes no but there was there wasn't like
there was a funny bone in every every
state there was there was a comedy
explosion right around the early 80s
that's true every town like had a a
bunch of comedy clubs uh it was exciting
it was also not so good because there
was too many clubs and too many Comics
which quickly burned down when did you
notice that like when you were you were
doing it did you now did any any of you
guys
that were doing stand up in the 80s did
any of you guys see the bubble like
bursting like there's no way you can
sustain this like yes of course how
could how could uh you know Columbus
Ohio have six comedy clubs I mean they
were just ridiculous and I remember uh
there was improvs at some point like in
so many cities and my great friend uh
Patron Bud Friedman I remember uh at
some point he moved to Beverly Hills
because there was improvs in every city
and the money was pouring in and there
he was in Beverly Hills and had this big
beautiful house and all this artwork and
then somewhere wait wait wait listen to
this I love I loved the new money
artwork okay that's one of my favorite
things ever all right let me finish
sorry I was laughing at your joke so I
didn't tell the joke yet which is that
he uh around 1990 I guess somewhere
around there
called me up and said we're having to
move
this is apropos to the point you're
making about the boom and bust and would
you like to walk through my house and
I'll give you all the artwork that I
can't afford to keep at the for just
what I paid for and I got some amazing
pieces like a vulture I swooped in when
you when a friend needed to sell his
artwork and to this day it hangs in my
house some amazing pieces that I got for
very little money and that's how I got
back at the club Owners bill that's a
man yeah wow he got overextended like
that when I was starting he was going
through his divorce
oh yeah that's when I started divorce so
his from Silver yeah she got the New
York com the New York yeah and you know
that famous story right that's not when
you started that he I remember he was
with Alex and he was already divorced
absolutely because or very soon but I
remember going to uh when David
Letterman had a Morning Show
I think it was 1982. I don't remember I
remember seeing it about something like
that and I remember going to a taping of
that and Bud was there with his new
bride so he must and of course bill in
1982 you were still in diapers I was 14.
I know I'm kidding because you're if
there was uh
yeah so she was long time divorced but
the story I had heard that was part of
the divorce settlement was she got the
New York Improv
and that he couldn't open another right
improv within a hundred miles or
something and he opened one in Atlantic
City and she got in her car and hit the
odometer and drove down then it was like
98 or 99 miles and they made him shut it
down oh wow
I'd never heard that allegedly before I
yeah she comes back and sues me no I
don't know about that
um but I do know that there were a lot
of improvs and I played them all
it's simply safe everybody you know if
you thought about securing your home
with home security but having been
putting but have been putting it off
you'll want to listen up right now my
listeners can order the number one rated
Simply Safe home security system for 50
off this is their biggest offer of the
year and you won't want to miss it
simply safe was named the best home
security system of 2022 by U.S news and
world report for a third year in a row
it's a [ __ ] Dynasty all right in an
emergency 24 7 Professional monitoring
agents use fast protect TM technology
exclusively from Simply Safe to capture
critical evidence and verify the threat
is real it is not a raccoon it is a
[ __ ] person
waste them HD security cameras for
inside and out smarter ways to detect
motion that alert you only when a threat
is real and even Hazard sensors that
detect fires floods and threats to your
home uh like that annoying neighbor
coming up your walk 24 7 Professional
monitoring service costs under a dollar
a day less than half the price of adt's
traditional professionally installed
system with top rated Simply Safe apps
stay in complete control of your system
this is where you just go you oversell
right they got it I mean we got another
[ __ ] page of this
um anytime anywhere arm or disarm unlock
for a guess access your cameras or
adjust system settings don't miss your
chance for massive savings on my
favorite security system get 50 off any
new system at simplysafe.com
get 50 off
um their biggest discount of the year
that's simply safe
simplisafe.com
there's no safe
like SimpliSafe
oh look who it is everybody are you
kidding me
the oldie but goodie doing the casinos
at this point it's all zip
recruiter are you hiring what type of
role are you hiring for maybe you need
to hire someone that where to wear many
hats I thought they said maybe an entire
somebody that wears a hat uh it's kind
of big which can be challenging or you
might have to have a position to fill
but it's taking forever to find someone
who's a great fit for your company
whether you need to hire a civil
engineer in New York a pediatric nurse
in Nebraska an attorney in Colorado or
even a mascot in Missouri zip
can help you find quality candidates
fast and now you can try it for free at
ziprecruiter.com from account from
accountants to zoologists and everything
in between
matching technology finds people with
the right experience for your job and
presents them to you for my money I like
the devil Read the best
um Ben that's the 80s album
Rob Halford wrote that up that copy
um then you can invite your top choices
to apply it's so effective four to five
employers who post on ZipRecruiter get a
quality candidate within the first day
try it now for free at this exclusive
web address zip
yeah I should say it zip recruiter
z-i-p-r-e-c-r-u-i-t-e-r.com once again
that's ziprecruiter.com uh Slash Burr
Burr ziprecruiter.com
slash Burr
the smartest way to hire I [ __ ] that
up I like when I go to ziprecruiter.com
the smartest way to hire
who uh now who did you start with
in the clubs like uh well there was
three clubs there was The Improv like
you mentioned on the west side that was
the granddaddy of the mall that started
in the early 60s as an Off-Broadway
place right it was like Place originally
I think became a pizza place and I think
that [ __ ] it did yeah because I remember
going in there because the shape of it
is still sort of the same because that
Richard Pryor
um live and smoke and he taped there and
it's just of course a total close-up so
you don't even get to see in the club at
all
um you taped there yeah he's got that
one where he's the one on 44th and Ninth
yeah wow okay well that was where the
first really the first urban Comedy Club
the place that really changed everything
from the Catskills which is
um you know way back when when that's
how Comics used to start that was the
you know borsche belt and then I guess
the Improv opened something like in 1962
I don't know but that was the first one
and then catch a rising star was on the
east side that was my club when I got
there like in the early 80s that was the
hottest club that's where Pat Benatar
started they had music acts there
um as well as comedy Richard Belzer and
you guys all hung out at the green
kitchen yes that was right across the
street these stores are all legends when
I when I came around Richard Belzer and
then there was the comic strip that was
a couple of blocks away on Second Avenue
that was Seinfeld and Eddie Murphy that
was like the Long Island Comics Larry
Miller yeah Richie tenkin yes Richie
tenkin and Bob wax who had previously
owned these blood buckets in the Bronx
but then they got you know
but then it was like okay we could you
know chime in on this comedy Trend and
and open a comedy club and they did and
it you know comedy was just off the hook
at that era so what that fascinates me
because I never talked to somebody that
came up in that era that actually said
that they saw in the 80s that's they saw
that coming I'm not saying you started
in the [ __ ] Industrial Age
I started in Mumbai in the 1500s yeah no
you started you started like the 80s now
absolutely fascinates me that you're in
the you're so you're in the middle of
something and you're going like I know
this is going bust so well what but you
have to be thinking well you think about
like the Crane's gonna rise to the top
or stay at the top or whatever well I
mean back then we the template we all
worked by was we got we're doing
stand-up yes but we want to get a sitcom
I mean even even Seinfeld got on Benson
Benson yeah
and we all thought it was great I
remember my friend Jimmy Brogan you know
Jimmy Brogan he got uh yes he got a show
where he was an angel what was the name
of that show I forget but I remember
seeing it his it was in TV guide and I
got the TV Guide when TV Guide was like
that big and it was huge if you were in
t if you were on the couch it was like
the famous person in the world he wasn't
on the cover but it was like fall season
new shows and like wow I know this guy
and he's in TV Guide he's got a show
um didn't last so that's what we all
wanted to do was here was the thing you
were you were working the clubs and you
would you would get
um enough shots Tonight Show shots which
were six minute shots of clean material
because this was the clean era and then
when you had like five or six of them
then you would do The Tonight Show
because you didn't want to do one and
then have not have material to do like
the next two or three or four
so that's what I did uh so what would
you do you'd Bank a five minute thing
like I'm not doing on TV I got that down
and I'm doing these you just built it
you just tried to have before you look
before you got in front of them you made
sure you had like 30 minutes of clean
stuff that was what you were supposed to
do right you know did we did it work out
that way not always it kind of worked
out that way for me I did my first
Tonight Show in 82 and I did for the
next like 10 years with Johnny while he
was still there I did like 31 shots that
scene out of every story I've heard
doing The Tonight Show the first time as
a comedian seems like the most
terrifying experience oh yeah it is I
mean it was literally like you're either
gonna make it or you're not it's
absolutely true because if you didn't
and I there was a couple of comics who
did not do well who kind of like spit
the bit and they never worked again
because if you did bad on like Merv or
something well okay that wasn't you
could shake off a Murphy right yeah you
could right you were you came on at four
in the afternoon right you you know it
taped it for in the afternoon it came on
at night but oh it did but you were but
you were like building up to The Tonight
Show all right but if you but if you if
you blew it on The Tonight Show it was
not good but of course it was cake
because Johnny would set you up the
crowd was dude if it was cake there
wouldn't be people
[ __ ] it up so what mindset you can
[ __ ] anything up because you're so
nervous but it was really yours to [ __ ]
up because the crowd was easy and Johnny
would do his like um comedy is the
hardest commodity to find and of course
at that point it wasn't the hardest
commodity fight you couldn't swing a
dead cat without eating a [ __ ] comic
in 1982 but he would still say that they
uh and we've got a young guy he's a
great observational stuff he's going to
do and Jeff Steinfeld I remember he
brought out Jerry with that God that's
how he pronounced his name Jeff Steins
you went out and I and you go out and
you do your little you know the first
one dog and pony show and you know
you've been practicing this six minutes
for like three years if you can't [ __ ]
it was like your Mantra so they give you
bullet points or you no oh no no of
course not I used to write it on my hand
in red ink so because red like you know
we couldn't see it as much but just in
case I went up I could I could and I did
that for every shot I had it was always
written in red on my hand
um yeah one time I had a nightmare right
before I was doing one of my Letterman's
and I was I don't know what the [ __ ] it
was I was just so nervous and I went
that I couldn't remember my act and I
turned around and my dad was sitting
behind his desk
oh
wow it's like psych 101 this is the
father figure of Comedy I won his
approval and I actually woke up in the
middle of the night whatever Hotel they
had and I just started laughing going
like Jesus Christ dude just do your [ __ ]
and it's funny because like the the the
the nightmare that so many people have
that I've had is that you're about to
take a test and you haven't studied you
ever had that no I I had
well that was actually that was my
actual my family career but I I
definitely had those uh
those thoughts of like you know what if
I forget my but you just don't but
that's it I'm saying what I used to have
that nightmare that I was about to take
a test and I completely forgot about it
and now I didn't know anything that was
going to be on the test and then when I
became a comedian that nightmare became
I was about to go on The Tonight Show
and I hadn't prepared anything and so he
was about to introduce me and it was a
funny funny young guy he's been with us
before Harry is built and there I'm oh
my God and I walk out I've seen those
curtains like oh my God yes and the band
you know that
you know it's like that that trumpet
sound and yeah so you finished your set
he gives you one of these probably I
don't remember I wasn't like how
[ __ ] high with you afterwards it was
over you delivered everybody slapped
yeah back you know it isn't [ __ ] I
mean what a relief yeah it is a relief
that's more than anything it's a relief
I didn't blow it I'm officially in Show
Business I'm at the very bottom but at
least I'm in Show Business you know I've
been flailing around in the water and
now somebody pulled me on the raft and
how many of those did you have to do
before you started selling tickets
oh no I I never you don't sell tickets
from doing 30 tonight shows not in the
80s I don't think yeah I mean I was
working as a comic but I still was
working as well first of all I gotta
again I was trying to get on a sitcom
and I did I got a sitcom and it's called
Sarah with Gina Davis in the title role
it was an amazing cast Gina Davis Alfre
Woodard right from her economy award
nomination still doing great still love
Alfrey Brunson Pinchot who went on to be
bulky in that sitcom I watched a lot of
sports I missed a lot of that yeah he
did see Thelma Louise though okay
I'm just doing that I'm just doing that
to [ __ ] with you but uh but uh so I got
on this I feel like math class I'm not
gonna pass this class that's what you
said when you were on my show you said
it's in our highlight reel you were like
you said like I feel like I've never
felt like what the [ __ ] am I doing here
like when I did your show but it was so
you had that guy who ran from there yeah
that guy [ __ ] ramped but it was so
silly I mean are you sitting here I I I
I I I feel like I want to be your shrink
because I think you're you're under your
file cabinets I don't think you're
qualified underestimating your
intelligence first of all you were the
mid-show guest when we used to have that
so you weren't even being asked to do
anything political or engage with the
panel on a book I could see I could see
why that yes they did of course we did
of course we did you you blocked it out
you we think we were trying to fool you
how that never happened it did but
anyway the point is he had old school
parrot point is oh I never did that the
point is you could engage on any
intellectual level you want you just
like to cultivate this image as you're
the regular blue-collar guy who doesn't
know that much and I know you know a lot
what you know what I know people
you know other things besides people
you're 54. nothing I know you hate to
hear that nothing yeah don't project
your age just [ __ ] on me
nothing in your world though like I
honestly I think anybody who watches fox
in CNN is a [ __ ] [ __ ] I heard you
say that the other day [ __ ] morons I
I can't watch cable news much either I I
don't understand I liked it better when
they brought the newspaper I like those
lies better and you just went in by
yourself and you just sort of opened it
up for me hey Marge did you hear they're
gonna knock down the [ __ ] store
whatever the hell they used to do you
didn't get to interact with other
[ __ ] morons well it becomes like this
atom bomb that's stupid I'm trying my
show uh on HBO is uh has always been
hbo2 and HBO Max it records Friday
nights at 10 p.m Eastern 10 p.m Pacific
and it is additional replays throughout
the week on HBO hbo2 yes it records then
Grandpa anyway yes it records boards on
YouTube and people actually now can
watch it anytime they want because
that's where the technology is moved can
you believe that anyway uh it's one of
the last shows maybe the only one that
is a legitimate debate show that
presents both sides it's definitely not
in the silos that what you're objecting
to I think and what I hate also is that
if you watch Fox News or MSNBC you only
hear what these people already believe
and you're never going to hear any other
opposition point of view and it's a
terrible way to run the country for
people there's no way to live it took
yes to get their news this would not be
challenged exactly never our fault it's
always because of what yeah what they do
and uh I I don't know I I know I agree
no trust me yeah and then I feel like
that's why they go after soft targets
you know like and it's been anything's a
soft target to them is what doesn't put
money in their pocket which is why
people can do horrific [ __ ] things at
a corporate level and they don't expose
it at all but what do you mean soft
targets like comedians oh I said left a
comedian it's got to be like the easiest
thing to be outraged about because it's
gonna cost you nothing and you're going
to get a big controversy going and stuff
like that to go after a podcaster or an
influencer or somebody who acts on a
[ __ ] TV show like none of those
things you mean go after them to cancel
them because they said something like
what they're doing is what's wrong with
the country rather than we can't drink
our own water now because corporations
it's poison or you came up with
synthetic heroin and killed a couple
hundred thousand Americans ah that all
just [ __ ] goes away
look who came up with synthetic heroin
pharmaceutical companies where can I get
it huh oh you're talking about opioids
all right yes absolutely that is it's
like the Houston Astros right thing
they're cheated at such a [ __ ] level
that they don't even talk about it right
they fixed the World Series but if you
have like a football that's allegedly a
contare lighter they'll talk about that
for [ __ ] eight years because it
doesn't affect anybody's money it's
silly it gets fans yelling and that type
of stuff I've watched I've watched the
whole Astros Yankees series and I've
watched this whole I've missed a little
bit of game two the Philly series and
they haven't brought it up once
they fixed the World Series they haven't
brought it up [ __ ] once well it was
litigated I mean the Astros certainly
were booed unmerstedly for a whole year
after I think it was 2017. that poor
babies no no okay I can give a [ __ ]
about the Astros I'm not defending the
Astros I'm just saying I shouldn't live
on forever and they didn't fix the World
Series they were sign stealing okay yes
it's everybody in sports by the way
cheats as much as they can get away with
you think there's a certain point you
think they're the first ones to cheat
but there's a no no my Pro my problem is
not that they cheated my problem is they
don't get [ __ ] for it that everybody's
just did get [ __ ] up for it and then it
and then it just stopped though well
should it go on forever like you know
what it should go on forever should
[ __ ] Ticky tack horse [ __ ] go on
forever because that does is okay but
the Astros are a very good team and uh
they're winning two games to one by the
way yeah so they're not good they're in
the World Series and they might win the
World Series I think they're good and
they're good without they're proving
that they're good even without the
cheating now should they have cheated no
of course they shouldn't and by the way
they weren't the only ones who were
doing that let me ask you the question
the Patriots didn't prove that they were
good I do share opinion about how they
made a big thing about deflategate when
it was nothing absolutely I share that
effect I laughed out of court
the judge was actually mad for them
wasting their time but you realize that
Sports in general does not matter it's
not important and it's a giant waste of
time I watch it also that's why I catch
it something I originally watched it but
now I watched it to watch the news
right I tried to be the guy that knew
stuff
didn't work well because there's no
Solutions
it's just they just present one horrible
thing after another that's not true
either and then you just watch people go
after the tale they're never the head
that's ridiculous there are many many
people in this world who are better off
because boring people locked in rooms
eating cold pizza at two in the morning
with stale coffee worked on yes drivers
excuse me worked on problems so that
lives could be made better and they were
that was one of the most Vegas longest
sentences I've ever heard in my life
well if you wouldn't interrupt me so
much I could finish what are you talking
about I listen to my whole sentence the
whole sentence that's right everything
is done in one sentence okay just let me
put some uh specifics there okay there's
guys in rooms with cold pizza working
long and hard exactly okay uh for
example uh senior poverty used to be 27
and then people worked very hard to pass
social security and now it's under 10
um child poverty we just saw an
incredible drop in that that's been a 10
because they have government agencies
who work on that are you suspicious that
those stats aren't right well I do
remember that once you were unemployed
after a certain amount of time they just
considered you not looking for a job and
they took you off of it okay but this is
we're talking about senior citizens
we're talking about senior citizens what
the bankers did in 2008 ended up with me
in 2000 whatever 12 when my roof
collapsed from water I had water I can't
have a serious political discussion with
the guy at the end of the bar who just
anecdotally throws something like that
out that has nothing to do with the
reality finish what now who's not
letting somebody finish okay finish all
right so I have insurance it's my
insurance I pay for it all right so when
the check comes out for my water damage
on my roof it's made out to me and my my
mortgage company and I have to sign it
over to them because of what they did in
2008 because they [ __ ] people so bad
in houses yes and so many people were so
upside down on houses that they were
like what's the point of fixing the roof
and then they would keep it and then
they would default on the loan and then
they get the houses back so they did
what they did and then they made me pay
for it and they and I had to do it
really slowly and they came over like I
was a child checking out you know did
you do the work and blah now you now
will release some more money and I could
have paid for the whole [ __ ] thing
and just been done with it and I had to
sit there be treated by a child by a
bunch of [ __ ] Crooks okay I'm not I I
can't even really Inga first of all I
don't contest any of that uh 2008 and
then the the Meltdown was just
horrendous on so many levels and I'm I'm
very sorry about your roof but I just
can't engage on this level of we're
talking about your roof
but it's because that's anecdotes
because you're trying to extrapolate
from your proof to making a statement
about America in general and how we
solve problems and of course your roof
is your roof
it is silly well it is silly oh you said
I was a lot smarter than I let on and
now you're talking down to me saying oh
you're [ __ ] roof
who am I bill yeah
I am who you need me to be depending on
what you [ __ ] arguing I I would say
you have potential to be and we still go
see Bill Maher at the Hulu theater
are you throwing me out I'm not throwing
you up I thought I thought you were
wrapping it up I was trying to break the
tension okay I thought you I thought you
were like going I've had enough of this
guy no I think what I'm saying is all I
do is you have the potential the
potential oh gee thanks coach but try a
little bit harder should I read my
little [ __ ] Protege uh start with one
and then see if you like it but it
doesn't think I read I do think you read
what do you think I read uh I think you
read uh Ted Williams biography guilty
guilty but I occasionally I do read
other [ __ ] do they have his head
somewhere right down the nose is missing
is that a ring on a can of tuna
what does that mean well there's these
flim-flam guys that came up with this
idea that after you die they could make
you Undead if they just froze you right
and then right some people but they
really did some people couldn't afford
to have the whole body front I see so
then they would just well we could just
do the head and then oh my God throw a
body like but why him
because
Talent Skips a generation and his his
son couldn't hit a ball and he needed to
make money I don't know why it happened
so he's evidently upside down well
and his head tipped over
so he kind of is a Splendid Splinter now
it's a [ __ ] messes me but he's not
there anymore that's just can you
imagine what it is you believe in the
afternoon can you imagine just his
vessel I do not but can you imagine what
his stats would be if he hadn't had
those two stints in the armed services
yeah he went both in World War II and
then again in Korea
if he had played those years what no
I've just like the guy that goes back to
another War I mean I can't
like well if that means you're like the
biggest hero ever you're just a [ __ ]
psycho like you just can't get enough of
it no I think I think once I did a war
I'd be like all right I'm good well of
course that's what you pilot season
wants to go back to a war but people had
a sense of responsibility I know they
did they are the greatest Generation
then they created you people the Boomers
all right we're so different from you
with our decade difference you are
you're still defending the Beatles
defending the Beatles like the Beatles
the famous podcast Bill Maher defends to
be why do the Beatles need defending
they don't okay actually they do
they do because the generation behind me
uh there's a number of guys like when I
was in my 40s if they were like in their
30s they would say the Beatles are
overrated and my head almost exploded I
was like you could not find any musician
of any Merit anywhere in the world to
back that [ __ ] statement and then
they would be like you know Yellow
Submarine oh yeah the Maxwell's Silver
Hammer you know they they had they
brought for self targets and also I I've
said this many times the Beatles could
put out an album called the worst of the
Beatles and it would still go to number
one but how about the fact that but you
could put but they're and they became
and they started their own label dude
they should have been over in two
summers well they figured out a way
around it well because they're because
they kept putting out better and better
amazing music I know but mixed in with
that is some [ __ ] and by the way their
lyrics they definitely could write some
good lyrics they also wrote a lot of
gobbledygook and they wrote a lot of
stuff that's just embarrassing doggero
like the Sun is up the sky is blue it's
beautiful and so is you that's not a
great lyric it's just not if you're
commercial fishing for a dollar that's
[ __ ] right on your knife
I like that that makes you feel good
commercial fishing that's good see look
at you yeah I watch Deadliest Catch
what's that it's a crab show
because these people that sit in rooms
alone on boats all by themselves and
they risk their lives to go get a king
crab for you how old are your kids
uh five and two five and two yeah oh you
got young kids yeah I'm an old dad
a lot of [ __ ] to work out bill
I had a lot of books tonight and read
before my kids got here do you like them
I love him oh good yeah no I love my
kids of course yeah no but there's a
silly question that's that's a no no
that is actually a very fair question oh
good it is no really I'm glad I did
something good no no I wasn't no I'm not
like sensitive after this I'm not saying
we're gonna blow each other in the
parking lot are you getting ready we're
so piss hugging
um um no there's uh there's people that
just have kids because they think that
that that's what you're supposed to do
and I have to tell you something when
you're going on at the playground yeah
and you see those kids and they need
that love and they're not getting it
it's one of the most heartbreaking
things ever and then you start seeing
their kids behaving in a bad way towards
your kids and you just you're seeing the
beginnings of an [ __ ] adult and right
and you just you want to interview I
feel like I can't what I see from the
outside and again this is just on the
outside because I hate kids but
um I love biggest kid kids either get
way too much love they're over too
overprotected by helicopter parents and
bulldozer parents and parents who are
way too in their lives or what you're
talking about here they don't get enough
there's no happy meal and I would say
that maybe you're doing what I did with
my roof when it comes to kids well again
I preface that by saying I'm saying this
from the outside I don't have kids but I
love that you say you hate kids though I
do there's a lot of never like kids even
when I was a kid I didn't like kids
and I and it has the one thing that has
not changed at all in my life I think
parents
make people without kids hate kids
because they won't quit gassing their
kids up to you even look at that here's
one over there right he just picked up
his dirty shirt and put it in his house
he is so smart it's just like they're so
overprotected I mean you want to be like
both of you are morons like two
negatives doesn't make a positive you
like two dummies can't make it we just I
had Halloween right and I was just
thinking parents would never let the
kids go out alone and when I was a kid
Halloween of course you know my parents
come out trick-or-treating with me what
get the [ __ ] out of here I mean that was
my whole life I used to come home from
school at I would fly up to my room
after school get into my play clothes
fly out the door my mother never once
said to me where are you going where am
I going kid stuff what the [ __ ] is it to
you what do you do between three and six
nosy [ __ ] I'm doing what I'm gonna do
I didn't say that to my mother but uh
but that's you had one of the best
Halloween costumes I have are you
talking about the crocodile hunter yes
you remember that oh my God I was I was
I love I love the crocodile hunter but
that [ __ ] outfit was hilarious right
right when I was a Crocodile Hunter well
right after he was killed by he was
killed by the stingray yeah I had the
CBS um crop Department make that it was
really Australia they told me I could
not go to Australia they said do not I
was like I'm not planning on going but
uh thank you for the note I will not be
going to Australia just that was like
such a stand-up
good moment where it's like what do you
love right you're going to attack I wore
it to the Playboy Mansion I remember for
their Halloween party it was amazing
awesome yeah isn't it sad that place is
gone yes well for guys it's uh it's it's
it's gone with the it's a real Gone With
the Wind you know a civilization Gone
With the Wind I went there I went to one
one party there really yeah I did the uh
the guy's Choice Awards yep on I was
total Meathead night I remember that the
award had was like antlers from like a
deer oh it was on it was on one of those
oh one of those Meathead channels yes
spikes I like to watch [ __ ] chicks
you know bending over a roast beef
sandwich it was like literally that
level of [ __ ] right so we would I was I
was a presenter Bill oh I had moved up
in the world
on the guy's Choice Awards on Spike TV
and then the after party was you know
the Playboy Mansion because guys like
that age right so we go back there and I
thought we were gonna go in the house it
was just standing in his [ __ ]
backyard looking at the pool like gee
Anna I guess that's where Burt Reynolds
used to bang 12 chicks you're just
standing there and then there was no
Playmates it was all like Hooters level
chicks just walking around
oh and he was roped off you couldn't
talk to him it got sad yeah and he had
his uh
whether you even had a license to drive
a boat you just started walking around
with the captain's hat that's funny yep
so that was my and I actually I stayed
there for about 40 minutes I don't
remember who I was with I was like this
is [ __ ] stupid yeah I'm standing in
somebody's yard right and he won't let
me in the house I'm obviously not wanted
here right he clearly looks like he
wants to go to bed and right I just got
my car I did try to walk down the
driveway to see the zoo uh he had a zoo
it wasn't near the driveway it was back
in the yard yeah he had his back in the
yard yeah yeah I mean you know it
explains what I didn't see it was you
didn't miss a lot there's some monkeys
that should not have been in cages lots
of things that should not I don't know
how
this didn't become a show in the last
like years of his life
he was attempting to sell the house but
the rule was you had to buy the house
but he he got to keep living there until
he and I'm like that is the the Bosom
Buddies reboot right there like some
young right influencer buys the house
well they did I mean he did live there
until he died but that he did not own
the house in the last years that's
absolutely true that's how it went down
he's in the magazine business or well
because I mean they had you know the
Playboy had fallen on hard times they
were look Playboy was kind of a victim
of its own success because the sexual
Revolution
which they sort of helped along
um overtook them I mean when the Playboy
clubs first opened and the girls were in
the bunny costumes that was about the
most risque thing you could see a woman
wearing in public right and at a certain
point women were wearing less on the
street so the Playboy club became very
passe and that's why they closed and
they closed that and he was really like
at the Forefront of booking like guys
like Dick Gregory and all that
absolutely he was I mean look things
have come out recently that have not
shed a very flattering light on what
went on the Playboy Mansion I sir I mean
I was there for parties I never saw
anything but I was never privy to the
the inner sanctums of anything but you
know I'm sure some [ __ ] went down that
shouldn't have gone down but he's
picturing you doing blow with like Dom
Deluise I never did blow away
[Laughter]
there was a lot of 70s detectives there
one thing I'll say one thing about Hugh
Hefner he was very loyal like once you
got on that list you could not get off
it Robert Robert Blake was still walking
around there uh and and Hunter and Long
Street and any every 70s detective was
still roaming around there uh Fred Dryer
absolutely all of them were there but in
the 50s and 60s Hefner was on the
Forefront of a lot of civil rights
issues that were that became I mean gay
rights and and
African-American rights he did he was he
was really quite a revolutionary at that
time no he just stayed too long at the
fair and that's what happens I don't
understand why in his older years like
when he had that Harem it's like we get
it you got a lot of Puss in you know I
mean you're you Hefner you don't have to
Guild the Lily and also so he used to go
out the coolest thing about him and the
Playboy Mansion was that he never left
the house when it was Chicago he left
the party came to him and then I used to
see him at the [ __ ] Garden of Eden
nightclub with his roped off area and
Seven Chicks I'm like why are you going
out to this shitty [ __ ] disco when
you have the Playboy Mansion that was so
cool about you what are you doing out
does that scare you as like a before
because whenever I see that I'm like oh
my God is that going to be me I mean
obviously I'm not gonna have a hair on
my chicks but it's whatever that version
of me is
where I'm sitting there no it doesn't
scare me at all like a central t-shirt
in my 90s I did things
because you're you're uh continually on
the ascent by the way you're a very good
actor you were really great and oh I
don't know what the name of it was but
you were [ __ ] somebody's mom and you
were oh that was uh
that was the working title of that movie
uh well oh yeah yeah yes fantastic that
was fun you can pull that off so you can
have them again but I mean you're gonna
have more of a career as an actor I mean
you know you're hopefully never going to
give up stand up because you're very
great at that I appreciate it but it's
true but um I mean why would you think
that you are going to devolve into some
caricature of yourself
because I mean you see a guy that was
like that guy was like bigger than life
Elvis Elvis died alone on a toilet but
that's what that's our advantage is that
we as Comics never get to that level you
never get to that level no seriously we
don't we're not musicians that gets to
people on a certain level and when it
does it [ __ ] up the person at the eye
of the storm because they just go nuts
and not to make everything about the
Beatles again but one great thing that I
admire about the Beatles is that they
were bigger than anybody ever and they
still came out pretty sane and normal
and nice did you ever made them live of
course not I was a yes because once
again I'm a hundred years old bill I
mean the k i was eight when they arrived
in America I was not ready to go to a
concert yeah but they played to like 70.
so by then you were like like they did
not they quit in 66 as everyone knows oh
touring yes okay so I was 10. I wasn't
gonna go to a concert and everyone knows
as everyone does know I don't know that
they broke up in 70 they but they
stopped touring in 66 but the one thing
I do admire about them is that with all
that Fame they never did anything that
made the fan go ugh I know what a dick
you know I mean John went a little kooky
but it wasn't like in a way that made
you hate him as a person he just he did
heroin for a while and God went a little
loony with you know put it out put out a
ride stuff like that but it wasn't
malicious and it wasn't about his ego it
wasn't erect he's classic right it
should have been because it looked bad
like I mean if you're gonna show your
junk you gotta have a shower man I mean
Jesus Christ a little bit all right go
ahead you know I always think of that
that you know the famous David the
statue David that the guy you know
the David no no that's Venus de Milo all
right all right I'm gonna tell you
that time I was in Italy right uh
me and my wife went to the uh the
Sistine Chapel okay so we're in that
thing you know it's boring as [ __ ] right
there's just a quick one just a quick
one where you get Sistine Chapel is
boring if you take the long route where
there's all the broken pie [ __ ] spoon
every Pope [ __ ] you know had his
cereal with I mean it's just I I don't
give a [ __ ] about old dishes I I don't
remember that part of it oh my God if
you if you bang a right or a left you
can avoid it and we [ __ ] up and we
went the long [ __ ] everybody's
[ __ ] James Brown robe that did mass
or whatever we get all the way out there
we get all the way out there and we're
standing there and it's ridiculously
small [ __ ] at room and it's all
shh like shut the [ __ ] up so I'm
standing I'm looking at it and you know
it was nice right so I said to my wife
because it was so [ __ ] long I said do
I go you know if I lived here
I would open a bar across the street
called the 17 Chapel and she was like
what
yeah I got the 16th chapel oh 17. that's
when she looked at me she goes it's the
cysteine oh lord I can't I I can't and I
can't even okay it's both on this one
right no oh oh I just knocked over my
water bottle no but like what is that
like a manly thing to know like you got
to know it's not a manly thing to know
it's just a thing to know the Sistine
Chapel is fairly famous yes let's end on
this all right can you give me all my
all my meat I've loved every second of
this by the way I have two okay all
right when you do Club random my podcast
absolutely and by the way mine I am so
high I don't know if you smoke pot but I
smoke it a lot and that's the whole
point of Club right now it's not
political it's you don't have to know
anything there's we actually got to
break up your weed on a [ __ ] The
White Album yes exactly I do that's
exactly how I smoke weed
um
but I really I mean I I've had so much
fun with this podcast it's a place where
where I specifically started it for
people like you who like were not
comfortable on real time but who I
wanted to know and who are very smart
people they just are not most people's
antenna is not tuned toward like the
political I mean one reason why you sell
so many more tickets that I could on the
road is because I'm sort of tagged as a
political comedian which is really only
partly true anyone could come to my show
November 12th at the Hulu theater in New
York
nice that's a promo and uh enjoy it even
if you're not even if you know as little
as Bill Burr wait I didn't say that
right no no but it but it's really true
but you have the reputation of being
more of an Everyman I mean I would love
to be able to not have to do your
podcast wait that came out wrong too
what I'm saying is oh is that why you're
here
um
no I'm here for that reason but I also
really did want to get to know you
better I really am an admirer you are a
great stand-up comedian you truly are
you deserve all the success
and uh and I also want you to do Club
random I want you to sit I will because
you would you'll find it it's very
different than any other podcast okay
well here's the thing really you said
that's something you should know with
the Sistine Capital
so for you know there's a lot of like
guys like me who uh and women who watch
you know know this podcast will listen
to it right so just so we don't do
something like that do you do you have
like just off the top of your head what
are the five things you feel the average
person should know they're at a cough
they're a cocktail party if they still
have those and you don't say something
done like the 16th chapel oh that that's
not important what's important for
people to know are things like
um the system of government we have is
based on checks and balances that's
important because we're about to lose
really the most fundamental part of
being an American uh there's an election
I don't want to get on my high horse
about this stuff it's not really what
this is about but there is an election
in a couple of days and we are going to
elect about 300 people into Congress who
don't believe in democracy who don't
believe that the person who gets the
most votes wins they don't care about
that and then we ended up there oh we
don't have time to go through all that
there are hope I'm a big proponent
the smartphone made us so stupid yeah so
stupid guilty uh but also but it's also
the schools we you can't expect people
to miss democracy if they were never
taught what it was supposed to be in the
first place if you say to somebody you
know we're losing our sense of checks
and balances their answer is what's that
and if you don't know what it is or why
it's important then they're not going to
miss it when it goes away they're just
going to say is the mask singer still on
because that's what I care about and
also the price of Pop-Tarts is through
the roof so I'm going to vote you know
Republican so okay do that but I'm
telling you things are going to change
fundamentally in this country after this
election and oh because you think those
guys are going to win is that well
they're definitely going to win are they
on both sides no no no no no seriously
no no oh are you one of those because I
don't subscribe to that that there's
only bad guys on one side I don't either
and I say it all the time I mean I'm on
Fox News all the time because I will
look I will take on not going to like
the ground round of news places no it's
just that just that I am very much a
critique a Critic of uh what goes on On
The Fringe of the left I mean woke
culture has just that's one reason why
the Republicans are going to do so well
in this election because the left has
gone super crazy with lots of [ __ ] that
the average American just never voted
for doesn't recognize in this country
doesn't want and pay attention to and
doesn't yeah so but there is only one
side that's pretty true that does not
believe in the idea that the guy who
gets the most votes wins I mean Hillary
Clinton thought for sure she had it in
the bag in 2016. but before the sun came
up she [ __ ] got in her black suit
with her purple lapels and came down and
conceded the election to Donald Trump he
still hasn't conceded the last election
and when it comes time for this next
election it doesn't matter whether he
wins or loses he's going to show up on
inauguration day and this time he's got
those 300 people behind him who are
going to back his [ __ ] and that's
when the rubber is going to hit the road
oh you're saying so even if you feel
like even if he doesn't he's going to
have the people to say that he did
correct that's what he didn't have last
time
it is politics is fascinating you should
watch my show no
you no I just think it's amazing that
you don't have to do it you just watch
it he went to that thing that dinner or
whatever and they stuck him right in the
[ __ ] middle so they could humiliate
them Obama and all those guys well he
deserves yeah I'm not saying that but
the fact that that guy then came back
and took that dude's job was like that
was like wrestling yes watching that
like when you think Hulk's not going
that last time it was down it stops
everybody starts doing this [ __ ] like
that it was a gangster move it was it
was but I mean he had spent years saying
Obama was not an American saying Obama
was a fake and that he was from Kenya I
mean it was horrible and racist what he
did and uh so Obama had every right to
make fun of him which was fairly gentle
I mean it was funny I mean it was it was
great I find the whole thing uh you have
to laugh at it because you know it's so
it's it's depressing it's depressing to
watch people on both sides absolutely
lose their minds and not be rational
like we went out to [ __ ] Halloween
last night right or what is it two
nights ago yeah last night two nights
ago yeah two nights ago and we're going
down the street and everybody's got
their scary [ __ ] or whatever and
somebody had a politically themed
[ __ ]
Halloween thing and I was just sitting
there thinking like how much it changed
where it's it's like first of all who
the [ __ ] is gonna look at that be like
you know I was gonna vote for this guy
but now that I saw that jack-o-lantern
you know actually wait a minute I made a
federal reserve one way back yeah
scariest thing I could think of was the
Federal Reserve look at that you know
about the Federal Reserve well that was
a joke about Trump it's not that he had
Direction he sent him to the wrong
[ __ ] building that's what it was
going after those
backs me
up the legendary
toe in the line and saying what the [ __ ]
he feels to the point of losing a TV
show which nobody did nobody did back
then it's gonna be at the uh the Hulu
theater at Madison Square Garden thank
you uh November 12th Saturday November
12th part of the New York Comedy
Festival correct Bing Bang Boom just
like that Bill Maher everybody thank you
for watching
dude that was fun I loved it yeah yeah
okay
[Music]
good morning podcast for Monday November
3rd 2014 how you how you doing Jesus
Christ
I'm trying to get comfortable here's
what's going on I'm in I'm actually
doing this uh my podcast in a studio
which I never do I always do it at home
land in my [ __ ] underwear
right now I'm in a studio the all-new
all things Comedy Network podcast
Studios uh one of the first guys over
here to do uh do my podcast and I have
to tell you it's a wonderful experience
so far and I already know what some of
you [ __ ] are going to say now that
I've given that information that I'm not
doing my podcast lying down you know
dude you're funny when you're not seated
gonna sit there and break my balls about
that I don't give a [ __ ]
go ahead and do it because by the time
you give me [ __ ] this thing is already
recorded what the [ __ ] do I care I've
gotten on with my life I'm down the
street having a snow cone you know
that's the life I'm living huh
wonder that you're not about this life
hit the white mainstream if I hear one
more white person [ __ ] say that like
that's that's gonna be the next
um African-American
uh expression
that they're gonna have like old white
grandmothers saying in [ __ ] cheesy
comics
sorry cheesy comedies
why when I sip that did it sound like a
fart there I just sipped some water
there um
you're not about this life oh [ __ ] the
old white lady said the thing the young
black kids say
if only she could give the finger and
there was an orangutan you'd have
yourself a comedy
um all right so how the how the hell are
you I had a long ass freaking week and
weekend uh
ended up going to a wedding
you guys like going to those things
going to weddings you know what I loved
about this wedding there was no dancing
okay and when you're as white as me
that is a very enjoyable moment you know
what I mean
oh my God there's going to be booze and
there's going to be no dancing and
you're gonna have a quick beautiful
ceremony
uh is there any way I can retroactively
pay for this this beautiful service it
was tremendous it's one of the best
weddings I've been to so I want to thank
those two people who got married for
having such a wonderful beautiful yet
Quick Service
that's what you want by the way when you
get married all you people out there
[ __ ] torture and everyone with your
long ass ceremonies
you know
like you're the king and queen of uh one
of those stupid countries with the Pasty
people over there in Europe who else has
a king and queen left over in Europe
is it like England
they're like the Wrigley Field of
governments over there right they got
these [ __ ]
jerk offs who just won't stop [ __ ]
each other because they got the same
kind of bloodline
so then all of them sort of in a
roundabout way look like the English
version of Eli and Peyton Manning you
know
that's the deal dude like when when you
[ __ ] okay or at least when you go to
procreate you got to get outside your
circle
okay you gotta run a post pattern
get off your block you know what I mean
can't start banging the girl next door
she's right there
she smelled your toast and all the [ __ ]
you were eating I'm telling you you're
gonna get like a [ __ ] I don't know
you're gonna get one of those weird kids
um who never wants to leave the town
right all he dreams about is driving a
[ __ ] truck to plow the snow
you know it was a big thing when I was
in Massachusetts you know getting a
[ __ ] state job
all those guys you know it's [ __ ] up
and angry and on edge
and as racist as Massachusetts is people
always goes why are they liberal why do
they still vote Democrat it's because
the amount of people there that want to
get a state job so they can lean on a
[ __ ] shovel or drive one of those
orange pickup trucks like a half a mile
an hour in the breakdown Lane
dude you're driving too fast [ __ ]
slow it down this is supposed to take
all day
I knew a guy a long time ago I worked in
a warehouse and he had he quit the
Postal Service
because he was bored out of his mind
it was a young kid and he knew somebody
and he got in with the post uh working
for the Post Office and he went out and
he did his route and he was done with it
by 11 and the old timers go what the
[ __ ] are you doing here
get out of here don't come back till
four o'clock you're gonna [ __ ] this
whole thing up so he went out and he
like went to the movies and got like a
sandwich and came back
and he just because he was raised right
he couldn't live a life like that right
now you know what I love it says
possibly
somebody who works one of those jobs
listening right now
and I want to I want to ask you how do
you live with yourself
how do you get up every morning taking
eight hours to do a [ __ ] two-hour job
how do you do that [ __ ]
you know what I mean do you really feel
like you're getting any like you're
getting away with something
just I mean it would be just be torture
just imagine like whatever just
make anything take four times longer
than it should
right
cooking yourself an egg in the morning
cooking it on low
just sitting there [ __ ] around the
thing being ready in like three minutes
12 minutes later there's a [ __ ] fried
egg
the worst example ever but you know what
I mean step on the gas pedal you piece
of [ __ ]
um no it's awful I'm so pro-union it's
ridiculous but I feel like so many of
the unions literally became what the
[ __ ] they were fighting and then they
just became [ __ ] and then the
corporations were like well you know
[ __ ] you then keep your union and we'll
take the factory we will move it
elsewhere oh look at this it's a third
world country
are there any laws even down here [ __ ]
it
we'll go back to playing people the way
we did before the Triangle shirt waste
fire there look at me oh who took a
double deck of tour bus in [ __ ] New
York I did this guy
all right what I just [ __ ] leaned
back too far in the chair and I
disconnected it you know what we you
know what this is a brand new studio so
we're gonna have some glitches
it was a glitch the Hat's just blew
um anyway so these [ __ ] people were
making shirts when you made shirts back
then you had uh you had a little bit of
waste you had shirt waste
long story short somebody threw a
[ __ ] cigarette in there I don't know
what happened they didn't have any fire
escapes and the goddamn doors were
locked and everybody had to like
basically jump to their [ __ ] deaths
and uh that was the reference it's not a
very funny reference but it is a
reference
um speaking of which did you guys see
that uh that virgin
uh airplane that goes out into space
crashed [ __ ] terrifying is that
dude the goddamn the balls
to be a test pilot
to go up there all right we designed
this thing
now on paper this thing should work
and then you have to go up there and
basically
see if it works and then once it works
you have to start seeing what how big
the the [ __ ] what the envelope within
this thing can perform in which
basically involves
what they what you know the whole push
in the envelope
like whatever just say you flew a
helicopter and they said you can't go
beyond 102 knots or else you'd get
[ __ ] uh retreating blade stall like
how do you learn how to do that that
means some [ __ ] has to go 103
knots a hundred and four because you
know when they say it's 102 you know
they they still stop it way before
but I mean somebody had to have the
balls to just keep pushing that stick
forward
I mean what the [ __ ] they think stand-up
comics are [ __ ] psychos
to be a test pie I mean
and then you know what's the worst thing
about that is what excites you after
that once you're on the [ __ ] ground
oh honey look I'm so happy you're home
look what I did I rearranged the
furniture here isn't this great it just
like opens up the room don't you think
why don't you just stare at me like that
when I say things I'm sorry I'm sorry
I'm not 30 000 feet off the [ __ ]
ground I'm down here holding on I'm
holding down the fort for you
where you coming from huh
did you get another [ __ ] after one of
your test flights
and what does he do he just stares at it
right maybe starts laughing like Ray
Liotta and Good Fellas
and that [ __ ] lap so he's wiping his
eye and he goes back out to a rocket
ship with Joe Pesci not that [ __ ] kind
of people are they that's your life
and you can't relate to anybody anymore
that's the deal
everybody's looking at you like what's
your [ __ ] problem
it's like what's my [ __ ] problem I've
I've been like uh
I went to the Moon
that's my problem I'm talking to you who
uh you know went to the Patriots Broncos
game and you got your [ __ ] eyebrows
up like what you just did was exciting
and I'm sorry I'm having a little
difficult a little difficult time
relating to you right now
you know
you know his wife is giving him [ __ ] you
have to stop bringing up the fact that
you've been to space
you know that you test pilots test
pilots you test airplanes anyway so um
so they got this plane that goes up into
space I mean and they're just gonna go
try this [ __ ] thing out the balls of
those guys
unfortunately didn't [ __ ] work out
dude this is no [ __ ] way do you
realize the amount of [ __ ] jackasses
slash former members of boy bands that
are just lining up to pay 200 Grand to
be the first [ __ ] jerk off
absolute [ __ ] jerk off to get on one
of those things
okay if you got 200 Grand to do it keep
it in your pocket
all right let other people be the test
pilot passengers for this [ __ ] thing
you don't do that it's like oh it's like
when when like a new [ __ ] iPhone
comes out when when they came up with
that Lasik eye surgery
you know and people were getting blinded
and they were [ __ ] it up because it
was new you don't [ __ ] with new
technology is all I'm saying
[ __ ] idiots
I'm going to go up in space
you're nuts
you're nuts what would you you know what
I actually got to think here what would
I rather do
what would you rather do would you
rather risk your life going into space
or go scuba diving
to me those are the two big the two
probably most terrifying things
I've ever seen in my life oh yeah I
gotta tell you this weekend I [ __ ] uh
when I went to that wedding
there was a uh
I was out in Palm Desert and um stayed
at this really cool hotel
that had this um
this basically Lounge act and I don't
want to disrespect the person but it was
a lounge and he was doing his act right
and uh you know older guys like in his
60s or whatever and he was singing the
[ __ ] out of these Frank Sinatra songs he
was great really was great
and um and it was fun watching the older
people watch the guy because in the end
he had all this whole this whole
patriotic thing that he did like a
salute to the Troops except it was real
you know what I mean it's just a
different time like these guys are like
uh
well wait a minute he was born in 1949 I
think I looked him up
so he would have been 20 in 1969 oh [ __ ]
that he's probably the Woodstock
generation
anytime I see old people like saluting
the flag I just think they fought in
World War II I think I watched too many
episodes of That Ken Burns the war but
whatever it was a nice thing
and uh the veterans in the crowd stood
up a bunch of old guys and all that it
was a really nice thing but in between
he was telling these uh he was 100
Sicilian he was telling these [ __ ]
old old
old school jokes that of course would
bomb in a comedy club but within the
context of what he was doing they were
great and uh one of the things he said
he said uh you know I'm 100 Sicilian
my uh
my birthstone is cement or something
like that which obviously you know
[ __ ] hey oh old time joke but it just
reminded me
of one of the worst deaths
I've actually thought about this like if
somebody ever uh
you know wanted to take you out and
you're standing on a [ __ ] boat in
cement that's drying and it's at night
and they're taking you out to the ocean
and then just gonna toss you [ __ ]
overboard I would be just standing there
weeping just going just shoot me just
[ __ ] yeah we can't man the blood
splatter we're gonna get caught
well can you [ __ ] shoot me as you
throw me in
just give me a gun
right as you throw me in I'm gonna pull
the trigger is that all right I'll count
two one thousand I'll already be in the
water it won't work
like what happens is there any medical
person out there is it a quick death
I just can't imagine you're [ __ ]
going down waiting for your goddamn head
to explode
and then you'd wanted like somehow like
just take a Big Gulp of water to end it
and uh you couldn't your body wouldn't
let you [ __ ] it oh my God you like just
kills me about that is you just keep
going down and down and down and down
way past
where all the [ __ ] submarines
anybody's ever [ __ ] gone you're just
you're gonna keep going
now granted the pressure
is gonna [ __ ] cave you in at some
point right
just the [ __ ] weight of that water
you know be worse if your survival
Instinct kicked in and you kept clearing
your ears as you went down for as long
as you [ __ ] could you just [ __ ]
like just some feudal attempt
to just survive you keep clearing the
[ __ ] air out of you use station tubes
you know so your [ __ ] eardrums don't
explode
oh Christ what a [ __ ] way to go and
that's all I actually zoned out
as he was singing what is a man
what has he got
death not himself
then he is shot right I just kept the
whole time he was singing then
to speak the words he truly feels right
I was just picturing going down to the
bottom of the ocean in cement shoes
and not the words of one who deals it
was like this little good fella film was
going on in my head I mean granted I was
a couple scotches in
oh you know what so um it was a buddy of
mine who got married and I was supposed
to get him some cigars and I've been so
busy with my day job
um writing on the uh or sitting in the
room pitching jokes on the soon-to-be
hit animated show in December of 2015. F
is for family I'm gonna hype this
[ __ ] show
I'm gonna hype this [ __ ] show for a
year so you guys better get you've got
to get ready
that's you know what I'm literally doing
like when they said this you know when
they hyped it and when it's actually
coming out it's like how long it takes
for a
a guy on the Mass Pike
to drive to a pothole [ __ ] a mile
away
um
anyway so I didn't have time to get the
cigars right so I got a hookup out here
to get the old [ __ ] uh
Cubanos there
and um
anyways this uh I didn't do it so I go
out to Palm Desert I'm like all right
there's all these old [ __ ]
staunch Republicans out here they all
got money
they all like playing golf they like
smoking [ __ ] cigars I know they got
Cuban cigars so I just don't go to a
smoke shop I look for a high-end [ __ ]
place that actually has a little bit of
a lounge thing right
you know [ __ ] Wooden Indian outside
and [ __ ] you know all the old school
stuff so I find one right and I walk in
there and I'm just like hey man uh it's
my buddy's
you know
uh he got married today I'm in between
the actually the wedding ceremony and
the after party I was supposed to get
cigars I [ __ ] up can you help me out
so he goes yeah sure come on in the
humidor so I say to the guy hey you got
any you know you got any uh Monte Cristo
or uh
you know part I guess any any [ __ ]
you know basically and he goes uh I go
you got some Cubans he goes well I got
these over here
and I go we got any Cuban cigars and he
goes kill but cigars are illegal in the
United States of America
I just wanted to [ __ ] slap him in the
face with a book of matches oh really
thank you like I don't [ __ ] know that
Jesus [ __ ] Christ
well maybe because I look like a cop he
said I mean what the [ __ ]
heroin is not legal with Linda you know
I know it isn't I'd still like some
I'm asking you to do an illegal
transaction here
I have cash I'm willing to I've never
[ __ ] been you know every place I go
to out here you just [ __ ] ask them
they have him in the back and this is
what's funny is people say they say this
[ __ ] right they'll go uh
you know actually uh like
99.9999
of the [ __ ] Cuban cigars in this
country are fake and you know what
they're wrong
because I've been outside this country
and I've smoked them and they taste the
exact same and then they're gonna say
well you know once Castro [ __ ] blue
blah blah blah blah blah all those
companies [ __ ] moved out of Cuba go
[ __ ] yourself with your theories
you read an article on one of those
websites that have lists I don't give a
[ __ ] all I know is that the Cuban cigar
that I smoked in Paris France tastes the
same as the one out here okay so
whatever it is and that thing tastes way
better than all of the [ __ ] legal
ones all those other ones that they say
oh this Davidoff [ __ ] Nicaraguan you
know tastes better
they'll test it higher than the Cuban
ones go [ __ ] yourself
go [ __ ] yourself you're still comparing
them to Cuban cigars and there's a
reason for it it's just like how every
[ __ ] car Compares itself
to something German or Italian or
whatever right
it's like a Ferrari except it's only 40
Grand
you know by the way
I uh
I'm gonna talk cars here for a second I
gotta um
what do I gotta do here I gotta read
some of the advertising for this week
Bill's gonna put on his [ __ ]
horseshoes here
he's going to read the advertising all
right live reads bingo bango all right
what do we got here one two three this
week people there's only three well
let's say we just knock them all out
right here all right all right let's
talk cause
um
so I've been threatening that I was
gonna buy a new car the old Prius is
getting old the old [ __ ] Prius she
ain't what she used to be
actually to be honest with you all I
need to do is uh get a little interior
work done
just freshen her up
but uh you know there's a couple cars
out there that I got my eye on one of
them was a Mercedes-Benz and
um AMG [ __ ] psycho level car right
and uh the other day yesterday I saw one
on the highway has this ever happened to
you you see your [ __ ] dream car you
see the car you want to and then you
drive up and you're like I just got to
see what the person looks like that's
driving it I bet they look like an
astronaut [ __ ] test pilot of some
[ __ ] right a war hero I dude I pulled up
along this car this guy could not have
looked like more of a [ __ ] dirtbag
who's like in his 20s
you know it just looked like a [ __ ] I
can't even
I can't explain it because I'll get in
trouble
you know
and not not really by the [ __ ]
politically correct police just by you
know this nationality of people like
they're they're like if pit bulls became
human beings
um
it just looked like a [ __ ] like if I
ever had a daughter and this guy showed
up at the door
to date her I I don't know what I would
do
I would do something [ __ ] crazy and
then I would start weeping afterwards he
just looked like the biggest piece of
[ __ ] ever and I was just like am I a
piece of [ __ ] well I am a piece of [ __ ]
but am I that kind of a piece of [ __ ]
is that what I'm gonna look like
but then if I get the car other people
will be oh that's my dream car and
they're gonna pull up alongside him see
[ __ ] Ron Howard driving the thing
it's gonna ruin it for
I think Mercedes-Benz ought to pay me
not to buy one of their cars
or at least give a free tinted window
packaged to me so it doesn't [ __ ]
hurt their uh hurt their product
um
I don't know but I'm gonna get one for
this and this is what I'm doing I'm
waiting let's you know right now I can
get the car but I have to wait till the
downstairs is done in my house
you know because that is a bad [ __ ]
move you don't want to go out and buy a
new car when people are doing work on
your house because they'll just they'll
just think like okay this guy isn't
spreading himself too thin this guy is
is just bottomless
all right it's not [ __ ] true I mean
you can get you can get yourself in any
car for like 1500 bucks now
Sonic goddamn lease on the thing they
don't give a [ __ ] they give you [ __ ]
eight miles a month oh that sounds good
right you drive home you're already over
the miles any any [ __ ] jerk that's a
thing now about cars back in the day
when you had to buy them you actually
had to be able to afford him so when
somebody came down the street in a
Cadillac or Mercedes or something like
that you could look at that man and it
was a man because those [ __ ] stayed
home back then right it was a [ __ ]
man and you could look and hold your
head high and go I wonder who the [ __ ]
he robbed to get that goddamn car what
did he do
you know that's the great thing about
being an Entertainer is people you know
you got to admit you know entertainers
we earned our money
we started out in the [ __ ] lounges
you know
I'm totally doing this lobbing it over
the net so you [ __ ]
[ __ ] out there can actually rip me
apart and say that I don't deserve it
um
no I think I'm uh
I just got to get through this [ __ ]
build once they just finish this [ __ ]
thing it's almost done people they're
literally they put in the hardwood
floors
okay I have floors downstairs now
they're putting the tile in
in the [ __ ] laundry room that's going
to be done
everything's gonna [ __ ] make sense do
you know my [ __ ] washer and dryer
were in a closet off of my kitchen does
that make any [ __ ] sense
put them downstairs now we turn the
laundry room upstairs into a walk-in
Pantry all right
so I can resell it someday because one
thing I've learned about women they like
being able to walk into something where
they can put a bunch of [ __ ]
you know they don't want to closet they
want to walk into the closet oh my God
look at this I can walk in and put all
my stuff here
they're in a kitchen they like the
kitchen but if they can walk into a
pantry I can put the flower over here
and a mixer over there I can walk into
it that's what you want to do
like if I was still a single man I would
build like some sort of walk-in closet
like a mini one like leading to my dick
right and then you just go out to the
actually didn't Justin Timberlake do
that he put his put his dick in a box
gosh you know not every idea is going to
be original
um anyways so anyway can I give you guys
a little bit of promotion here with the
all things Comedy Network that was uh
it's a podcast Network that I um
I started with uh Al Madrigal
and a couple other Fellers and
um it's basically uh you know
it's basically owned and operated by
stand-up comics and we don't own
anybody's podcast we don't try to [ __ ]
anybody out of money all right but
things
things do cost money so we're having
this fundraiser here the all things
comedy five dollar fundraiser starts
today
all right our goal is to outfit the new
all things comedy studio in Hollywood
with a professional quality AV Equipment
uh go to tubestart.com buy a sticker
that says I support all things comedy
for five bucks shipping included the all
things comedy live podcast number four
by the way is available today on iTunes
subscribe rate and review it this
episode features uh John Heffron Jackie
kashane I'm the worst reader ever Dean
Del Rey myself Al Madrigal and Felipe
Esperanza uh you gotta listen to him did
I say his name right Esparza Esparza I'm
the [ __ ] worst
um and you know in such a [ __ ] crime
that I didn't say his name correctly
because he had the best goddamn stories
I've ever heard you got to listen to it
um
such a white guy from the [ __ ] East
Coast I get anything remotely Latino I
can't even pronounce it
um
that's embarrassing I've listened to all
of his [ __ ] comedy too what a piece
of [ __ ] I am anyways check it out it's
going to be on iTunes
um all right let's get back to the
podcast can we talk a little football
um yeah I'm not gonna brag about the
patriots beating the Broncos I'm not
going to do that I'm not going to act
like you know Tom Brady is better than
[ __ ] uh Peyton Manning I'm not gonna
do that [ __ ]
I'm not gonna do that all right
you know the record speaks for itself
head-to-head matchups I hate when people
do that look at at least seven to two
against a lifetime well I guess that
means he's a better quarterback
I think it all comes down to uh you know
when you had your opportunities what did
you do with them all right that's
basically what it is because everything
else is you got everybody else on the
[ __ ] field
you know people always come up with a
reason to blame it on the biggest guy
and I don't think that's necessarily
Fair all right although that pick six he
threw against the Saints was his fault
I'll give him [ __ ] on that one and but I
also think Brady should hit Wes welka
guy was [ __ ] wide open he threw to
the back shoulder Welker oh she should
have caught it just a [ __ ] shame and
then what happened next thing you know
Eli
the [ __ ] middle child ends up with
more rings than Peyton figure that one
out
you know but the thing about Eli that
you gotta love about that guy
is as much as he looks like he always
has a cold
the bigger the game the better he plays
so I [ __ ] love that guy despite the
fact he his team kicked my team's ass
twice in the Super Bowl
but you know what when you've won three
others I guess a little okay you know I
realize the Patriots are actually have
been in
um
I think more Super Bowls
how many we've been in Let's see we lost
to the Bears we lost to the Packers we
beat the Rams
we beat the uh the Panthers we beat the
Eagles we also the Giants lost the
Giants that's seven our record is three
in foa
I think the Cowboys have been in the
most Super Bowls
what's their deal they lost to the Colts
then they beat Miami
right so those were two
and Miami beat the Redskins and then
Steelers beat the Cowboys
then the Cowboys beat the Broncos then
Steelers beat the Cowboys so that's five
they've been in eight
and then they beat the bills twice
and then they beat the Steelers
so they've been in eight Patriots have
been in Seven Super Bowls how the [ __ ]
did that happen
ooh the goddamn doormats of the league
um playing in that high school football
stadium
unbelievable but um yeah I'm not gonna
brag about [ __ ] uh
um you know we also let up 21 points we
still suck against the run and it's also
a regular season game and all that type
of [ __ ] so like I said I'm not gonna
really [ __ ] brag about that um I am
happy that we won and all that type of
[ __ ] uh but I gotta be honest with you I
have no idea who the best team is right
now
um
I mean can somebody explain to me the
San Diego charges what the [ __ ] is that
like
if you bet on football this year you're
out of your mind at this point you
should just just cut your losses and go
home
37 to nothing against the Dolphins
you know no no disrespect to the
Dolphins but the [ __ ] Dolphins 37 and
nothing I missed the whole game so I
should just shut the hell up I was at
that stupid
not stupid event I was doing that event
thing um as a sports fan of me saying
that it was stupid
um
but whatever so I haven't I have no idea
I don't know I don't know who shot I
don't know who's not I don't know who's
good I really don't and um
but the Patriots look how the Patriots
look every year to me
um since we stopped winning Super Bowls
so
you know I think we're once again I love
that that we're somehow number one
against the past
that's great but uh
I don't know it'd be nice if we could
have been at least
seventh against the run as opposed to
like dead last I'm quoting somebody from
last week I might be wrong about that
but uh
you know so whatever I hope I hope um
you know whatever I know we're gonna
make the playoffs obviously because that
division [ __ ] stinks
and uh I don't know what about that Jets
Jesus [ __ ] Christ one and eight thank
God for the Raiders or they they'd have
the worst team in the league
unbelievable I'll tell you right now you
know it's going to be a [ __ ] bargain
to pick up is Rex Ryan when they fire
that guy because that guy is a good
coach I don't like that he talks [ __ ]
and disrespects other [ __ ] teams and
he does and it comes from a place of
insecurity I think and then he told no
you can't get mad at me oh I respect
shut the [ __ ] up you ran your mouth when
you had a good team now your team stinks
so now you now you now you're not
talking so maybe he is a good guy maybe
he did learn his lesson I'm gonna wait
for Rex Ryan to have another good team
and if he doesn't talk [ __ ] then I'll be
like all right he uh kind of learned a
lesson then but I think most of the
reason why he's kept his mouth shut is
because his team has stunk however
um I will say this
um
that that team is not his fault
uh they uh you gotta get rid of that GM
you know
coaches only as good as the players I
sound like one of those stupid analysts
on [ __ ] ESPN but it's true the guy he
doesn't have anybody
and Gino Smith from what I heard was the
dead GM's that was his big [ __ ] pick
you know what are you supposed to do so
uh whatever so he's gonna get blamed
he's gonna get fired the GM's gonna get
fired and then someone's gonna pick up
Rex Ryan I think you know if he gets if
he gets with the right GM I think you
know that guy took the Jets to like
within two plays
uh or one drive I should say of getting
to the Super Bowl the [ __ ] Jets
that's an accomplishment in itself you
know so
I don't know it's weird I used I
remember for the longest time I used to
wish I had switched the Jets would lose
and I [ __ ] hated Rex Ryan because he
was talking all that [ __ ] I wanted to
see the guy flame out exactly what the
[ __ ] happening and now it's happening
and I I feel bad for the guy because I
feel like uh what's going on is not his
fault
I wanted them to lose with the [ __ ]
players that he picked because he talked
all that [ __ ] [ __ ] you know we're
going to win a Super Bowl we're the best
[ __ ] team with this [ __ ] League
all of that [ __ ] just throw me up the
goddamn wall but now it's now attack I
can't root for a guy to lose his job
can I
yeah Jesus I don't know
um anyways what how much how much time
have I done here by the way Mike well we
started over didn't we or this is this
is the real time 37 minutes all right
um 37 minutes in
uh
all right what the [ __ ] else am I going
to talk about
oh I did a I did a benefit benefit uh
for Pit Bulls last night it's one of my
favorite benefits of the year because I
absolutely [ __ ] love dogs and I also
showed up and um
there's all these pit bulls there that
need to be adopted and stuff and uh
they're just the best the best [ __ ]
looking like if you drew a dog's face
that's what a pitbull you know
what their face looks like that is just
a [ __ ] dog
so I went over there and there's all
these poor dogs that had their [ __ ]
ears clipped and [ __ ]
you know they went through all this
goddamn pain and they're just sitting
there you know they're looking scary
because if [ __ ] ears are all cut up
and [ __ ] so I go over to pet this one
right
great [ __ ] dog it's one of those dogs
where you start petting it it like leans
into you it puts all its weight on you
and I wasn't prepared for that and I
squatted down like a catcher to pet this
thing and it just [ __ ] leaned into me
and actually knocked me over
oh
but uh ah it was crazy they had puppies
there
you know if my dog wasn't such a psycho
and wouldn't try to fight another dog if
I brought it in I would own three of
them
so
I just got to ride it out with the crazy
dog that I love now give her the best
life possible
um but when that chapter is over I'm
gonna get uh I'm gonna get a Blue Nose a
red nose
I'm gonna get an all-white one and I'm
gonna get a black one
I'm gonna have four of them and even
then that won't be enough that's how
much I [ __ ] love that breed of dog so
it was uh
it was a [ __ ] great time going over
there and uh doing the show actually I
did two shows
and the first show went great the second
show I don't know what happened
I think I went out I went out too hard
there was a comic in the room that I
wanted to impress uh comic that I liked
uh when I was starting out and I may
still like them obviously but uh I tried
to [ __ ] that's I swear to God nothing
will humble you like [ __ ] stand-up
comedy every time you think he got it
down
you know like I got this [ __ ] figured
out
what ends up happening you know you go
up there and you I didn't eat my balls
but uh
I definitely uh I I munched on him a
little bit
hahaha
I swear to God I thought I said I
thought I said it the same funny way I
went up there and I said you know what
I just hope that when it's all said and
done all the money we raise here tonight
some of it trickles actually trickles
down
to some to the dogs or something like
that because you know all these half of
these [ __ ]
these goddamn uh
charities
are total scams
just as far as like uh
you know the amount of money
that goes towards whatever the hell
they're trying to stop versus what they
line their pockets with I mean it is a
sh it's a scam somebody sent me
something where you know the amount of
uh Charities out there that that they
name their charity that almost sounds
like the legitimate charity you know
like that um
that coming to America instead of
McDonald's it's McDonald's they do that
and these [ __ ] pieces of [ __ ]
we'll just put a picture of a starving
kid or something like that
and then you feel bad you drop some
change in there a couple bucks and they
just keep it and they go out and they
get a house
all right we had another glitch with
some of the wires here
the [ __ ] was I talking about it'll get
better people it'll get better
if you get down there get your all
things comedy five dollars fundraiser
stickers
um do we even have a website
Mike do we even have a website where I'm
supposed to tell these people to get
these [ __ ] stickers at
all right there go to tubestart.com if
you'd like to stop hearing delays in
this podcast now whatever we'll figure
it out anyway so these [ __ ] they start
uh they start a um
a uh what do you call it a charity and
they name it like another charity that's
actually legitimate and then they put
some you know sad puppy's face or uh who
the [ __ ] knows what and then they make a
bunch of money next you know they got a
big house sitting by a pool and they
don't feel one ounce of guilt they're
absolutely you know what happened to
these people if they actually did
something like that in Singapore
you know where it's illegal to spit gum
on the sidewalk I can't imagine the
caning that these people would get and
they would [ __ ] deserve it too as
horrific as a caning video is
um
I actually have a theory people
Oh Billy gossip is coming with the
theory I've noticed this year uh
you know a lot of stuff came out about a
certain campaign
that uh that was Raising awareness that
made everybody wear the uh well it's not
quite a magenta
pink the pink campaign a lot of [ __ ]
came out
about that a lot of unsavory [ __ ]
[ __ ] over there about that campaign
about how much money was being raised
and how much was actually being
appropriated toward actually finding a
[ __ ] cure for breast cancer
and how much was going into uh new
tiling inside this person's [ __ ]
Olympic-sized pool
and also a lot of [ __ ] came out about
the NFL and their pink jerseys
and by a lot of [ __ ] I mean the website
I went to and the one article that I
read
um
about uh I thought it was a legitimate
website I mean it was on the internet
right and they were saying that like you
know like 95 percent of the profits from
those jerseys went into the NFL's
pockets and I think that people were
starting to blow whistles
and but the NFL makes so much [ __ ]
money
for media Giants ESPN
[ __ ] Fox and NBC that they all kind
of squashed it and I think that the pink
lady in the NFL both made their money
and they slowly backing off each other
and just gonna pretend it never [ __ ]
happened because this year they went
from oh my God if I see another [ __ ]
pink thing again in my life
um
I'm gonna kill myself last year
you couldn't escape it I mean I remember
when I was in New Orleans working and
there was like a
I went to this casino in the blackjack
table that was two years ago the
blackjack table was pink it was all
[ __ ] over the place and now I noticed
this year straight across the board the
NFL and everywhere else way way way the
[ __ ] tone down
way the [ __ ] tone down and I think
they're all slowly walking away
from uh some unsavory [ __ ] they're just
acting like it never happened hey you
know
whatever we should like that crimes and
misdemeanors where somebody got killed
but nobody got caught you just kind of
get over it after a while you just get
on with your [ __ ] life I think if I
had to guess uh but then I'm a negative
I'm not a negative prick I'm a cynical
son of a [ __ ] and uh I think that
that's what happened
someday that Oprah will make a [ __ ]
movie about it right
the Lifetime network someone will play
the pink lady no Oprah wouldn't do that
right that's
that would make women look bad she's not
about that if there's a guy
you know what it just they say it was
based on real events and then somehow
they would make the reason why the evil
woman at the head of the pink campaign
did it was because some guy was verbally
abusing her or hit on her when she
walked down the street
it was a couple of another like
non-stories and stand-up comedy
like the the [ __ ] outrage you know
back when I was a kid when people got
outraged what they did was when they
wanted to find out if people were
actually outraged they they went out in
the street and they talked to people now
it's like marketed outrage so I don't
even buy into it
you know what I mean
like uh this comic
they did this whole [ __ ] thing this
woman made a video she walked around New
York City for 10 [ __ ] hours 10 hours
yeah you [ __ ] walk around in public
for 10 hours as a good looking woman
somebody's gonna hit on you right
that way they should follow me for 10
hours it'd be the exact opposite instead
of people hitting on me like hey
acknowledge me
and then the end I get mugged
Jesus Christ bunch of [ __ ] crybabies
now you know what I love all the [ __ ]
clothes she was wearing were made in a
sweatshop somewhere so as much as she's
having a [ __ ] problem people calling
out how nice her ass is there's some
crying child that made those jeans that
are so wonderfully cupping her booty
cheeks you know and you know I think
that's one to grow on
I Don't Give A F I think that's
something it's just a bunch of [ __ ]
everybody flipping out about such a lazy
goddamn story and then you know where
they always get started some fat [ __ ]
blogger's sight
but some victim douche makes a [ __ ]
video and then they always end up on
those cheese balls sites those list
sites that steal six hours of your life
top ten turtles in the Indian Ocean all
of a sudden oh geez I wonder what those
look like you know how the [ __ ] did you
end up there
the top 20 worst plastic surgery
nightmares the top 100 uh porn star blow
jobs
in the month of March I mean as much as
I'm making fun of them I obviously
because I can make fun of them I know
what the [ __ ] they are but um I don't
know I'm just
uh you know it's it's I I don't think
there is any outrage I don't and I think
one they just they just find like two or
three [ __ ] people and they just try
to magnify it
right someone will get upset about
anything like this [ __ ] that chick up
there in Oregon who had an inoperable
brain cancer and decided that she rather
than go through it she just wanted to
die I was actually reading this story
she went to Oregon because if you want
to die up there they let you do it
um
you know and the hospitals are like wait
a minute how dare you decide to die and
we don't make any money off of it the
God damn it this goes against the Lord
you need to come into our hospitals and
lay there
and we'll medicate you and we'll just
drag this [ __ ] thing out and uh then
stick your alive relatives with a
six-figure bill how dare you go around
all of that did she basically uh
medically speaking was off the grid so
she decided to go up there I was
actually [ __ ] creeping me out
you know she went up there and she
picked out the house that she wanted to
die in
she picked out like a little yellow
house and uh and then just basically
took drugs like I'm dying now do you
realize the [ __ ] nerve that that
takes
I couldn't do that as much as like uh oh
yeah I could if you were gonna put
cement shoes on me
and you gave me a cyanide pill
which is probably a horrific death too
but uh it's nice and quick
yeah I'd do it but I'd still have to
psych myself up you know trying to think
what prayer I could say to a higher
power just in case it actually exists
that would exonerate me from all the
[ __ ] horrific [ __ ] that I've done in
my life
um
I don't know if I could do that
what would you rather do would you
rather just go to Oregon and die in a
yellow house hanging out with your
friends just watch a football game be
like all right everybody listen man I
had a great time I keep going home
see you later man all right just [ __ ]
Pop A Pill
I don't know guys I I got nothing I
don't know what the [ __ ] happened this
week oh I here's one for you Kansas City
uh Kansas City Royals lost the World
Series man that killed me
I wish they sent that guy home
you know even if you got thrown out at
the plate just to have a [ __ ]
somebody try to get an inside the park
home run in the ninth inning down by one
bottom and a ninth at home
Jesus Christ I was watching that in the
bar and um the second it it went by that
guy
I'm thinking all right that's a double
then it went down there it bounced off
the wall and that guy kicked it or
something I'm like that's definitely a
triple you know what kills me if that
was Willie Wilson running the base path
he definitely would have made it oh that
[ __ ] would have made it he would have
made it and then you know what you would
have had you had one of the you would
have had one of the great plays in
Baseball however if anybody's gonna sit
around and give that guy [ __ ] his like
you know he should have gone
the same reason why he didn't go is why
that guy in center field missed the
[ __ ] ball because it was the ninth
inning of the World Series you know what
I mean there's so much on the line that
was the regular season that guy just
would have let the blooper drop in but
he ran in thinking I gotta make a play I
gotta make a play and then the second I
hit the ground he looked like me out in
the field
you know
I actually make fun of myself a lot
athletically like I stink and uh that
nothing could be further from the truth
a lot of people don't know I was
actually drafted by the Texas Longhorns
to play baseball but uh I just decided
you know
I I mean I just Roger Clemens was still
there at the time and I was just you
know I was just like you know it's his
time it's his time I I don't want to do
that to people right
is anybody watching hockey at all I've
been so busy [ __ ] looking at all this
other [ __ ] I have had no time to look at
whatsoever although I do know
that uh
that the [ __ ] uh Bruins beat the
Senators the other night didn't they
three to two they shifted up the line
it's bergie's line there they got my
shine and the other [ __ ] line or
something but people I'm basically out
of [ __ ] to talk about maybe for the
first time ever so I'm just gonna sit
here and uh
just can you guys just ride with me for
the next couple weeks while I well I'm
gonna we're gonna write and record these
next couple episodes and then I'm gonna
be done with the f is for family [ __ ]
then we're gonna animate it then I'll
actually have some free [ __ ] time and
I can actually live a little bit of life
and maybe actually have something to
talk about on my goddamn podcast Mike
what am I up to here like 50 minutes 51
minutes I gotta somehow figure out
another nine minutes of [ __ ] that I have
to talk about and you know what you're
not gonna help me you're just gonna sit
over there go oh we got another glitch
we've got another glitch in the [ __ ]
main board here
Mike has that ever happened any podcast
in here it hasn't right
what is with me in technology it's just
it just doesn't [ __ ] work out for me
I don't know
all right whatever
corpse found in a Costa Rican concordian
wreck assumed to be Russell rebello no
way not [ __ ] Russell rebello
ah Jesus Christ this is my [ __ ] phone
who is it
oh [ __ ] I gotta take this guy sorry
hello
hey I'm finishing up my podcast can I
call you back in two seconds
okay cool bye
this is how bad I am with with
technology the reason why I went over my
management calls I always pick up is
because I know they probably sent me an
email that I didn't see
and I'm supposed to be somewhere that
I'm not I really [ __ ] hate the fact
that people can get away with now well
you know I'm like dude why didn't you
tell me I sent you an email
why don't you just send a [ __ ]
carrier pigeon that doesn't fly back to
you and like you should send a parrot is
what you should do send me the message
and then the parent comes back like I
was able to give it to him and he read
it right you just send a [ __ ] email
did I just imitate a parrot is that how
much I'm [ __ ] struggling to fill time
yeah I don't [ __ ] like when people do
that [ __ ] they think I I sent you an
email it was all in the email
it's like dude I get a thousand [ __ ]
email much porno I've watched on on uh
on my computer
Jesus Christ you know how many [ __ ]
emails I get a day I've bought [ __ ]
on all of these [ __ ] websites I can't
even find emails anymore I get so much
stuff and then people oh why don't you
uh why don't you just start a second
account and you know on that one you
know it's only for friends and family
and all of that [ __ ] [ __ ] because
eventually I'm gonna have it open
and I'm gonna look at somebody uh you
know [ __ ] blowing somebody and then
next thing you know they're gonna they
somehow they just get it there's no more
privacy or whatever so that's the reason
why I took the phone call I apologize
that was unbelievably uh not
unbelievably it's probably typically
unprofessional of me
um
yeah so anyways all right what do I got
going on coming up uh anyways you know
what I'm just gonna hype the [ __ ] that I
do have coming up I got a stand-up
special coming up uh December 5th I know
I've bored you to death with this but uh
I'd love if you watched it it's on uh
Netflix and I've been getting [ __ ] about
this that it's only on Netflix and that
you're not gonna be able to buy it
anywhere for like a year
and all I have to say is you only have
yourselves to blame for that all right a
few cup [ __ ] [ __ ] would actually pay
for the goddamn thing I could put up my
own money for it
you know but I can't put up my own money
for it because only like maybe I don't
know 5 000 of you will actually purchase
the thing and that'll get me 25 Grand
back of about 180 Grand so would you do
a deal like that you wouldn't so
whatever Netflix put up the money
so that's how it works and then part of
my agreement is that they own it
exclusively for a year that's how it
works but here's the thing you know some
[ __ ] some gonna whatever you [ __ ]
Tech Geeks call it rip it and wrap it
and [ __ ] upload it and it's gonna be
on YouTube anyways so you'll just see it
that way
okay so quit breaking my [ __ ] balls
about it
it's [ __ ] nerds man
you out there you know how come they
just keep making movies about [ __ ]
superheroes and then uh Transformers and
[ __ ] and apes taking over the planet
because you stole all the other ones you
stole it
you stole all the [ __ ] you get what
you pay for you stop paying for movies
so now they're like [ __ ] it we're gonna
make these movies that even if you steal
them it's gonna suck to watch at home
they're either gonna make those or
they're gonna make little cheapies
little cheapy ones well you gotta you
know you gotta share a sleeping bag with
the five other actors and the directors
every day on a shoot those are the only
[ __ ] movies they make anymore and you
know what you [ __ ] cunt's got no one
to blame but yourself so I don't want to
hear it so my special comes out December
5th on Netflix all right I should have
called it you you get you get what you
pay for oh is that what you should have
called it Bill whoa now what's gonna
happen huh is some group going to get
upset
who's the latest guy Chris Rock got in
trouble
Chris Rock got in trouble he got
outraged
he got some outrage he told some joke
and and people were outraged some people
or some groups how long you know what's
funny about what he did was there's no
real group I guess Boston's strong
they could get outraged
they could pretend to be outraged so
they could sell more t-shirts so then
they can line their [ __ ] pockets and
then uh you know maybe a couple of it
trickles down
to the actual victims of the bombing I
swear to God like I would like to start
it you know what the charity you should
do is you just walk up to the person
who got injured in the in the bombing
and you just hand him a bag of cash that
insurance companies can't see so they
don't say that this well you're now
making this much money so this somehow
cancels your policy we got to somehow
come up with something where you just
get the money directly to the Wounded
Warrior directly to the victim of the uh
uh the marathon bombings you know as
opposed to these Mary Kay cosmetic
[ __ ] [ __ ] who are standing in
between the the money and the victim
like a [ __ ]
they're sitting there like like a
windscreen I literally have my arms out
right now acting this out just catching
as much of the cash as they possibly can
it's like a filter
I don't know I'm not saying they're all
bad
but generally speaking you know what I
mean
people are [ __ ] people and I yeah you
know I don't trust them I don't [ __ ]
trust him
this is bad him I you know what's funny
is uh at some point I I'm hoping to get
to the level
in this business that actually somebody
will take the time to get offended by
something that I say although the second
show last night
you know it was David Spade was in the
crowd I don't want to drop the name and
I'm a [ __ ] huge fan of his so I
wanted to impress him and then I went up
there and I [ __ ] Ate My Balls I
didn't eat my balls
ah he [ __ ] kills you know and that
was like the last set of the night it
was my last set so now that's just
lingering there so fortunately tonight
I'm actually at flappers
I swear to God that's the name of a
comedy club
I don't know why they always have to
give them zany names like Zanies
right wackos bananas
[ __ ] [ __ ] whatever the hell they call
them this one's called Flappers and
evidently it's because back in the day
I don't know there was people that
people who danced
you know like during the vaudevillian
days hey let's get some Flappers out
there you know why we get the you know
well the comics I don't know getting his
puppet
whatever the [ __ ] they were doing right
so whatever so they named this comedy
called Flappers and then all of
waitresses and [ __ ] got addressed like
it's the 1920s and then the guy who runs
the room he's got a [ __ ] dress like
he's got a [ __ ] tommy gun in a violin
case
I don't know why they do it I don't know
why they don't sit down with other
comedians that have a meeting and just
say hey do you think this is a good idea
oh speaking of which you guys got to
listen to the versy effect this week
another all things comedy uh member Paul
verzi
um somebody threw a [ __ ] beer bottle
at him thank God they missed
they threw a [ __ ] beer bottle at him
and first he did said he did some Matrix
[ __ ]
and uh the guy missed him but like this
is just classic Comedy Club security
like dude I don't know if you guys
realize but but
throwing a beer bottle at somebody's
[ __ ] head is assault with a deadly
weapon
like you literally can lose your eye
cave in your skull
I had a buddy of mine in high school
somebody smashed a bottle in his face
he's scarred for life I haven't seen him
in years but I mean he had this big scar
going from his forehead right down the
side of his face totally affected him
socially like when he talked to him he
would cheat his face to the side he was
this outgoing guy became all [ __ ]
self-conscious and all that [ __ ] right
and um
this guy does this [ __ ] classic Comedy
Club security
do you know they didn't get the guy's
name and he just [ __ ] left
they're like oh he just ran out of here
it's like what do you mean he just
[ __ ] ran out how does he just run out
he threw a [ __ ] beer bottle at
somebody
hey just fat I don't know he kind of
slipped through our fingers
just [ __ ] ran out the door like
Charlie Chaplin I'm not saying you got
to go fight the guy but with all this
cell phone uh camera video that you can
get now you couldn't videotape his
[ __ ] car
that videotape whatever I'm so old
whatever you couldn't get a VHS tape of
him driving out of the parking lot just
something a picture of his car anything
that guy should be in [ __ ] jail
I'm sorry it's a good friend of mine
somebody threw a [ __ ] beer bottle on
him um anyway so if you want to listen
to the full story of it uh listen to the
verzy effect this week and um
that's it mercifully I'm up here in an
hour I apologize guys I had uh you know
I didn't get it done this week you know
I think I started off strong with the
test pilot [ __ ] and I ended kind of
weekly or maybe I didn't maybe you guys
are actually enjoying it and I just
can't hear the laughter
um this weekend
if you are in Boston Massachusetts I am
doing uh the 20th anniversary believe it
or not I can't believe it because I
think I was on the second or the third
one that's how [ __ ] old I am the 20th
anniversary of uh a great charity where
the money actually goes to the people
that need it uh the cam Nelly uh Cam
Neely house
Comics come home the 20th anniversary uh
Dennis Leary is gonna host it as always
he put together this charity with Cam
Neely 20 years ago
you know from day one it was a big deal
I remember the the year that we did it
they actually filmed it for uh Comedy
Central and uh now somehow it is in its
20th year I remember a few years ago I
was in the 15th year and I was like how
the [ __ ] is it 15 years
you know it feels like two years ago
five years ago goes by like two years
now at my age so it's kind of terrifying
but anyways it's gonna be a murderer's
row of Comedians and uh as far as I know
I think they're putting me on last as I
mentioned last week and that and that's
what you do on that show you do not
headline you go on last
so I gotta make sure my my game is uh up
to Snuff
so uh I don't get [ __ ]
I don't get a bunch of [ __ ] you know
what's funny was the wedding I went to
this week uh I hung out with a a buddy
of mine that was from Boston and I
haven't been around that vibe
that like that much that consistently
it's just the level of defensiveness
somehow we started talking about
sneakers
and uh
we were saying how you know oh you know
people will stand in line for sneakers
and people get beat up and shot over
sneakers and sometimes these sneaker
heads they buy these [ __ ] sneakers
and then they put them in the back of
their closet so they can break them out
five years later so people like oh [ __ ]
where'd you get those
and this dude totally [ __ ] bosses
just like
just like yeah dude I I don't get that
you know
like my whole life like
I never been into [ __ ]
you know
like I'm not
I'm not into [ __ ]
like really choppy talking
like we're just having this conversation
just kind of jumps in like that and
we're just looking at him like what do
you mean you're not into anything you
like to fish he's like yeah dude but I
wouldn't like buy a [ __ ] pole and
then stick it in my closet and pull it
out five years later oh look at this
[ __ ] like every [ __ ] thing was like
that he went up to go uh
do a drink run
and he comes back he's like yeah dude
what the [ __ ] with that bartender you
know
I go up there to order you bourbon the
guy's like do you want it neat do you
want it on the Rocks it's like dude I
don't want the [ __ ] that means just put
it in a glass
you know what the [ __ ]
so anyways I'm gonna be performing for
people like that next weekend to raise
money for uh the Cam Neely house
um all right that's it I'm sorry oh he
ended with the whimper
he came in like a douche and ended out
like a [ __ ] all right that's a podcast
for this week uh I'm getting new and
comfortable to the all things comedy
podcast here
um please go to uh all thingscomedy.com
check out all the other web uh websites
all the other um podcasters that we have
on there and once again if you'd like to
help us here
go to tubestart.com and uh buy a couple
of stickers you can do it if you want if
you don't who gives ah [ __ ] I didn't
talk about Halloween
I gotta talk about Halloween real quick
this is like a comic that will not get
off stage he's just trying to get the
last big laugh Mike's over in the corner
like for [ __ ] sakes I got a life to
get on with you
um I've we finally figured out we
finally figured out Halloween this is
the way you do it because last year we
did not give out candy because my lovely
wife was so [ __ ] sick of all the high
school kids and the precocious [ __ ] kids
and the [ __ ] uh adults that show up
and they want candy and they say [ __ ]
up [ __ ] this is how you do Halloween all
right
the first hour is the best it's all
little kids little cutie pie kids with
parents who are excited and it's their
kids like first or second Halloween the
first one the first kid that showed up
to the door he was dressed like a little
fireman right and I'm like oh look at
you little fire man how you doing and I
you know I crouched down and uh I hold
the bowl out to give him the candy this
adorable little kid reaches in grabs one
of the candy bars and then goes to hand
it to me
how would I'm like no no you get to keep
it you get to keep it [ __ ] adorable
as hell right uh and then he turns
around he goes to walk away the back of
his jacket his ring his little raincoat
said uh fire chief it was adorable as
hell but then he stopped was hilarious
he stopped and he walked back and he
reached and he grabbed another piece of
candy and put like he got it you know
and I was thinking oh that's cute slash
he's on his way to being like these
[ __ ] kids that are going to be coming
here in an hour so there's an hour of
these cute kids and then the next hour
you get these precocious kids right
who think everything they say is so
[ __ ] brilliant and that adults are
stupid
right and these kids come up
and as I'm going to give him first kid
you know there's this group of kids and
one of them comes up to the door and I'm
just like he looked like he was the Grim
Reaper I'm like oh the Grim Reaper he's
like oh I'm not the Grim Reaper I'm so
and so from like either Harry Potter or
[ __ ] Lord of the Rings I don't know
what he was supposed to do and it's just
like dude [ __ ] you you look like the
Grim Reaper
how many houses are you gonna go to when
they guess Grim Reaper before you blame
yourself that you made a bad costume you
little douche right so I'm like I'm
sorry man I didn't see the movie and he
goes well could you at least read the
book
I wanted to [ __ ] boot him right in
his seventh grade ass
and then another group of kids they come
there and we all [ __ ] give him candy
and then they start singing We wish you
a Merry Christmas We they start caroling
on my front porch like this is blowing
my mind like I'm gonna be like wait a
minute what holiday is it that's what I
can't stand
it's the fact that they think that
they're smarter than you this is why
it's so great I never had kids I would
have been such a bad parent because I
just want to be like do you think you're
really [ __ ] with me right now
I had water damage on a house I have a
[ __ ] mortgage I have a goddamn wife
do you think right now what you're doing
is blowing my mind
huh you little [ __ ]
I just I don't know and then what we did
so then we wrote it out through those
douchebags because still there was some
little kids cute kids coming up and then
what you do is the first [ __ ]
kid
who looks like he's pushing uh High
School age
and has that [ __ ] eat and grin look on
his face
what I should have done was just slam
the door in his face said he was too big
but I didn't because I don't want
anybody [ __ ] with my house what you
do is you let him one guy get you you
give him the candy and the second he
leaves that's it you blow out the candle
and the Pumpkin you shut off the porch
light you just shut it down it's over he
shut out all the lights in your house
and you go down into the bowels of your
house or into some closet and you just
pour yourself a drink